the jobs report came out it's really bad
and uh lots of people getting fired or
quitting from their job quitting their
jobs and I love this uh uh uh you know
Joe Biden I love this guy he comes out
and he's like it's actually a good thing
that people are losing their jobs amid a
a abysmal jobs report and mass shortage
of everything the beef prices through
the roof like at least what we're
looking at it's like double the cost gas
prices through the roof I just saw the
gas out here we're in the middle of
nowhere and it was like three 330 or 340
or something and I'm like wow it's a
good thing I got electric vehicles
because I was like I'm planning ahead
man that's that's what they're trying to
do right
so uh I guess we have to talk about
what's going on with Joe Biden being a
bad president like we always do because
um what time is it oh yeah it's today
it's it's it's it's a day ending with
why yes so um we've got uh uh don't walk
run Productions you want to introduce
yourself Andrew hello I'm don't walk run
Productions great intro yeah who are you
what do you do uh I'm Andrew uh from
don't walk run I have a oh yes please
adjust that camera there we go uh Idaho
I always I always change there we go
thank you hide that double chin much
more flattered there we go Tim knows
um while while Tim the The Mastermind
here it's been a week to uh
this this time last year
was my very first appearance
do you guys you won't you weren't here
but do you remember uh what the subject
was what the hot topic was when I was
here what was it it uh it was when Trump
got copen oh wow and and uh the the
audience share was just through the roof
I remember that yeah yeah I mean once it
was fun today it was like it was a
stretch before the election with views
were it was crazy back then now we're in
an off cycle year it's like the the one
year in the cycle so next year we got
midterms we've got primaries and we got
the general so this is the year where
like no one cares but you know we talk
about it anyway but but now we have Joe
Biden who's just like a godsend for
Content you know
so bad and as the senior political
analyst the the top senior political
analyst on on YouTube I'm very happy to
be here and I I always appreciate the
invite and sorry I've been been away for
so long Tim Cass so he literally just
ran up the stairs like a minute before
I was stuck on the tarmac uh longer than
I was actually like flying on a plane so
uh you know glad to be here ah brutal
I'm glad you survived well I hate to
break it to you but Luke's here too
I would agree with you Andrew uh Biden
but I am the senior the top senior
political analyst that's what you're
gonna say right no no I was questioning
the the status of uh don't walk around
when you almost came in late but uh more
importantly I would agree with you that
Biden is great for content and also
destroying the economy welcome back
beautiful and amazing human beings the
sloganowski here of we are change.org
and something strange has been happening
to my YouTube channel ever since kind of
being on here the the views have kind of
plummeted all videos are like 10 out of
10. it's weird so if you guys want to
show me some love and check out my
channel it is youtube.com forward slash
we are change something really weird is
happening in the algorithm I don't know
what it is but like views cut in half
and uh doesn't really make sense YouTube
doesn't like us you're saturating your
audience that's what's happening it used
to be when when I used to hurt your
channel just haven't be on your just
just on on being on your channel now
you're hurting my channel so uh I think
that's good I think it's a great sign to
see in the in the coming times yeah you
know it's coming back it'll come back
yeah it's an off year man this is now is
the time where it's like politics are
out the window everyone's kind of like
uh but next year is going to start
ramping up and it's gonna be brutal and
awful and everyone's gonna be miserable
oh 20 asteroid 2022 yes you know but
this is the midterm so it's like an
asteroid for every congressional seat
that's fine the US getting peppered by
meteorites the whole point we got we got
uh Lydia press on the bus I'm also
pressing buttons Ian's taking the night
off tonight I know you guys are gonna
miss him we only have these two guys
we'll have fun anyway
um yeah I'm tagging along as well I
press buttons for a living it's a good
job me and Ian wanted us to let you know
that his his magnetic field is out of
sync yeah he just needs a night he
wasn't feeling it so uh he will be he
will be out but before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
you know we have a special members
podcast yesterday because it wasn't just
like a normal riffraff of the crew
hanging out James O'Keefe descended Upon
Us indeed and we had a little bit
shorter but James gave a direct update
on all of his lawsuits so the the
battles that he's in that he's launched
to stop defamation to go after these
these liars and the results and it was
actually really fascinating we got to
ask him a series of questions as he
talked about this and the people's uh
defamation defense fund AKA what they're
we're doing is they're doing this
project Veritas legal and how they're
saying you know James said he wants to
find a couple good cases where he can
help regular people who have been
defamed before the end of the year check
that out at timcast.com become a member
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends it's Friday night
everybody yes it'll be good live from
Harper's Ferry it's Tim Cass Friday
night here's the story from the daily
mail when you see Mass firings look at
the bigger story although the bigger
story Biden appears to defend the
unvaccinated losing their jobs appears
to he literally defended it saying look
at the bigger picture the people who
lost their jobs don't matter meanwhile
I'm just going to jump right into it U.S
jobs growth unexpectedly weak in
September thank you Financial Times
unexpectedly yes I've been buying
emergency food because I unexpectedly uh
I'm I'm shocked by what's happening with
the economy and the cost of beef the
rice shortages the gas prices the steel
the lumber the labor shortage the
trucker shortage I tried ordering some
stuff off the internet I don't even know
where it is it's gone yep these are the
worst job numbers for his entire
presidency and he says this is a sign
America is moving forward yes into the
dumpster into the into the trash into uh
just economic Armageddon and and just
Financial ruin for the rest of America I
mean a lot of people need to understand
that that the pain out there that it's
felt is so wide is so vast I mean people
were just lambasted they had so much
government in their life that the
lockdowns the unemployment benefits the
labor shortages the supply shortages the
continued mandates the continued rules
and regulations are literally standing
in the way of free capital from moving
around and then some people are still
wanting more government for some reason
I just I just don't I just can't I can't
understand it you guys got a lot of
government what does government look
like directly getting involved in the
economy printing money out of nowhere
and hyperinflating the currency robbing
you blind well you know Joe Biden
wonders why he's like he's like it's not
happening fast enough or maybe just
maybe if you weren't scaring people
every day oh my goodness why do I have
to do like okay I have to do I have to
do the Joe Biden thing unions that
create the middle class
look he's
scaring people everything's like
either pandemic of the unvaccinated no
it's not it's a it's a global pandemic
it's a global pandemic right we will
never get to zero we can't get to zero
because we're we're one of hundreds of
countries on the planet right well well
specifically with his statement about
the US getting 98 that won't happen
either because a large portion of the
population lives in the middle of
nowhere you know Joe Bob who live in the
mountains is not going to be like well
I'm gonna go drive down two hours to get
the city to get that vaccine he's gonna
be like I live two hours from the city
I'm right it's gonna stay I don't see
anybody but but also but also you have
to realize when he's saying that look we
we need to protect the vaccinated from
the unvaccinated okay but you're
vaccinated right so basically he's
saying if you're vaccinated
there's a risk that you're going to get
to covid and you're you know and and
it's going to be that the big bad man
who's unvaccinated and he's he's the one
that's going to give it to you so you
know we need to get everybody vaccinated
and you're like well wait so if I'm
vaccinated
I could still get it so maybe I won't go
to that restaurant maybe I won't go
shopping maybe I won't spend that money
on that maybe on that TV that I want
because I might need it for medical
bills later because the president said
that I'm probably possibly gonna die so
you wonder why it is that with all these
job openings people won't take jobs how
many people in cities are like I don't
know man I don't feel good like Joe
Biden's telling me that even I'm
vaccinated but it's not just Joe Biden
even the New York Times the New York
Times got slammed because they put out
the story where it was like the
vaccinated are equally as likely to
transmit covid and what they meant was
if you are vaccinated and you get
covered the transmission rates are
comparable but what people got mad about
was they're like yes but the New York
Times didn't include the the statistics
that you are substantially less likely
to get sick if you are vaccinated right
that's that's the whole point
it's it's not about it's it's not about
stopping the spread anymore and and it
never really was and the New York Times
just uh I guess I guess like a month and
a half ago they put out a story saying
it's it the odds are one in five
thousand that you're gonna be
hospitalized if you're vaccinated and
you catch covet right or you know
basically you're
like oh well maybe it's one in ten
thousand depending on the area it's like
no it's like
uh Jesse Jackson and his wife got
covered after being vaccinated Chris
Rock Brett Kavanaugh right yeah Brett
Kavanaugh uh the Dave Chappelle the the
the Texas Democrats that fled the state
right they're like oh it's one in it's
one in five thousand breakthrough cases
like then how how did six or more on a
plane on the same plane get it you know
like statistically you can't say that
it's one in five thousand I don't know
one in ten thousand when it's all these
people that are getting it but but I
don't have an argument for like our
arguing over statistics statistics I can
say though when it comes to math when it
comes to what Joe Biden was saying about
jobs you mentioned this just before the
show Joe Biden's like look at United
Airlines you know 59 were were
vaccinated now it's 99 and it's like
when you fire the people who aren't
vaccinated the proportion of those who
are vaccinated goes up now a lot of
people did just go out and get the
vaccine but you know what you know what
worries me about this at a time of
hyperpolarization the people who are
being forced by their bit by their jobs
and by Joe Biden to go get vaccinated
are not happy people they're com they're
completely stressed out like the posts I
see online where people are like
freaking out on Facebook like convulsing
like because it's like you lose your job
you can't feed your family or you do as
you're told and get a medical treatment
you don't want and there was there was
one woman who was applying for a
religious exemption who got denied who
said she felt like she was being raped
like something was being forced in her
body and she couldn't do anything about
it and it's like well it's certainly not
the same thing but I can certainly
understand being put in that position
people are they feel like they have no
choice and when you back some people
people into a corner like this you'll
get a dangerous reaction and
if you look at all the help of the
healthcare workers who were celebrated
all last year you know I I remember
hearing people clanging pots and pans at
7 pm every day to celebrate where are
you based out of uh well at the time I
was in New York I was um I was in Bush
not anymore I was in the no see see
everybody listen listen okay I've been
saying get out of cities this guy did it
yeah he did uh okay yes I did yes I did
I I did I did leave and I I'm I'm
Florida man now yes yeah that's what I'm
talking about yeah no look look it's
it's you know taxes are so ridiculous in
New York anyway you're getting fleeced
you're getting robbed literally
figuratively just by living there in New
York City you know if okay first of all
let I'll talk about this
let's do the pots and pans okay nurses
well pots and well which was annoying
anyway right and then they stopped as
soon as George Floyd happened like then
then people were like then they were
shooting off fireworks every night you
know yeah as a rebellion yeah yeah
because they were doing that and then
and the whole time I'm I'm there and I'm
just like this is like this is
ridiculous the cops aren't doing
anything you know there were houses that
were being burned down because of
fireworks right which people don't think
about right so
all of my tax dollars
it's like what am I paying for what I'm
I'm paying for the the mayor's wife to
say hey let's take down statues I'm I'm
paying for uh a mental health initiative
that cost a billion dollars and has
nothing to show for right I'm I'm paying
for ranked Choice voting where where
Andrew Yang oh and that's something we
could talk about too that's ridiculous
uh but I was like I can't I can't live
here anymore I want I always I wanted to
live in New York
my entire life and then and then I did
and I had I had a girlfriend who wanted
me to move to Columbus and I'm just like
and you're originally leaving New York
City that's crazy it's crazy but you're
originally from Stone Mountain Georgia
correct
does anybody get that reference yeah do
you get the reference yes all right
so I moved I moved from
yeah so I so I moved so I moved to
Florida uh a few months ago uh I do not
miss these lockdowns I don't miss the
vaccine passports I don't miss anything
New York I'm sorry like you're you're
going down in flames and and uh there's
there's just nothing left it's like it's
like when Luke Skywalker when amparoo
and Uncle Owen were murdered and he's
and he's like well you you know
Obi-Wan's like you're gonna come with me
to all the rain it's like I got nothing
here that's it like I got nothing in New
York you know I find it kind of weird
that he didn't like break down crying
that his family was just you know just
murdered and their corpses were sitting
there well well Luke you know Uncle Owen
wouldn't let him go to the Toshi station
to pick up some power converters so he's
like really salty about that so he's
like good
I hate Luke I hey I hate Luke Sky he's a
great character Luke Skywalker is he's
he's the whiniest little piece of
whatever I I know we're talking about
Star Wars apparently I know it's a hot
take how many other tangents can we go
on we're gonna go all over to play
anyway so I moved I moved to Florida and
and it's great and it rains every other
day and uh and there's I have sent a
little air conditioning and no
construction happening and it's just
really no no state income taxes so no
fireworks at two o'clock in the morning
no no rats carrying pizza slices down
the stairs
tons of lizards tiny little lizards
those are cool though I love it I think
they're so cool now the rats in New York
because of the lockdown have been
hunting they've been going out in packs
and hunting have you seen this I believe
it
there used to be so many tourists that
there was food everywhere and the Rats
would just hide and then eat refuse and
then run but now they're getting
desperate and hungry and so the rats
have started coming out in packs hunting
and chasing people and stuff I'll tell
you what I just realized though we had a
bear attack a bear came onto our
property in the middle of the night and
it tried ripping into our chicken coop
and we didn't know what it was at first
but we have three layers we have thin
chicken wire and then we have this kind
of like aluminum wire it's not really
chicken wire because it's bigger but
it's like it's stronger it's thicker and
something ripped it out of the ground it
was buried ripped it up and broke it
apart and I was like this can't be a fox
because normally we have the fox but the
the chicken coop that we have is on an
island surrounded by parking lot so they
normally don't come out this far and
then our neighbor told us that there was
a bear
why would the bear come out that it's
desperate normally the Bears don't cross
the river but the bear was desperate and
it was hungry and then I realized with
the lockdowns it's not just about the
rats it's about all of the wildlife that
would normally go and ransack a garbage
bin or something now there's less food
now people aren't going out as much and
there's less litter which means they're
going to be hungry and they're gonna be
Scavenging more but it depends where
you're staying home though yeah I mean
in Florida more people are out partying
more than ever people are flying in just
a party in Florida but there's also the
cases of the monkeys in Thailand because
of the restrictions of Tourism a lot of
the Thailand economy has just been
absolutely devastated and there's roving
gangs of monkeys literally fighting each
other in Street Warfare and we're
talking about like 50 monkeys fighting
another group of 50 monkeys for
territory for food because they're so
desperate and they can't get any because
there's no one feeding them there's
there's no food around there's no trash
around so um I mean I think that's a
perfect analogy to maybe things to come
especially in our social economic
dichotomy that's uh
nature right you know in New York it's
rats in Thailand it's monkeys rats and
gangsters Venezuelans you know it's uh
hello okay bears are legit they're
awesome I no I I want to own a capybara
in my lifetime yeah I think they're
awesome another thing that's important
to note here is that when we have kind
of economic Calamity and the lack of
Economic Opportunity we also see crime
rise up so recently I saw a whole bunch
of mainstream media articles saying
crime's up 30 25 uh 35 in in all the
different cities and and it and it's
pretty clear uh you know just in the
United States alone crime has
dramatically gone up and I think that's
in part because of so much Economic
Opportunity just being swindled away and
ruined by the federal government not
just with their lockdowns but with their
continued interventionist policies that
are absolutely destructive towards a
free market that have obliterated it
created more poverty and because of the
poverty we have way more crime than we
used to before and also this Lacks idea
of giving someone a slap on the wrist
for you know shooting up a school uh
which has happened
hold on we got we got we got some good
news and some bad news all right let's
we'll carry forward yeah good news the
good news is that people didn't die the
good news here hold on is that what
that's going on
Republican support is doubling in rural
Factory towns where you'd expect
Democrats to have leads like Union towns
the bad news is Republicans don't do
anything anyway so
well here's a story from the Daily Mail
Republican support and Factory towns in
rural areas has doubled in comparison to
Democrat gains in cities and college
communities in another worrying side for
Biden's party before 2022. there's also
good news and bad news so I'll say it
again good news is that people are
finally saying yo the Democrats are
ripping us off it's bad I'll vote
Republican the bad news there's one of
the Republicans going to do Mitch
McConnell oh then the good news and bad
news mixed together depending what your
perspective is this is also talking
about Democrat making gains in cities
well people who are here's what I think
is happening you know people uh who who
you know grew up in Stone Mountain
Georgia and moved to New York City
realized that it was better way back
home and left the city taking that red
vote out of the city making it Bluer and
making the other Suburban areas in more
rural areas more red right like you
well I don't know how much of a an
impact my single vote is going to have
in my area which is but you're just kind
of heavily but there's a lot of people
like you though and Florida is still a
swing state every national election oh
for for natural for a national national
election sure but uh you know and for
for uh you know a senate or that's fine
but my local congressperson or you know
city council and all that my vote's not
likely going to matter too much unless
you know the the area is inundated with
with disaffected Republican New Yorkers
you know but I've been to Florida
there's a lot of them there's there's a
lot of people there especially in Fort
Lauderdale I never leave my apartment so
I couldn't tell you yeah I'm so I'm so
boring I'm so and there's nothing it's
just like you know malls and stuff and
Outlets I've been to Orlando the the
city center yeah has really been uh I
don't know it was just weird being in
there it was like there's like sort of
elements of like New York City in there
the bad parts of New York City but
outside of it it's beautiful and amazing
and I remember staying on this Farm in
Orlando just on the outskirts of Orlando
and meeting some like natural organic
farmers and homesteaders finding a
really great Community out there of of
you know liberty-minded individuals that
were very self-reliant which was really
cool and awesome but inside of the city
I was like ah this is a crab hole to be
honest with you were they all in Disney
World no where are you outside a Disney
World we did visit one of the theme
parks which is Gator Landing you went to
Gatorland yes
this is what Fridays are like yeah
I was gonna I wanted to bring up you
know like is a red wave gonna happen
okay all right well all right let's I'm
I'm sorry I didn't not mean to derail
you Tim
my world Luke Skywalker
and uh well hey you're the one that
you're the one that brought up that I
that I moved so
um you know that's that's political you
know that's all on you man uh look you
you did an amazing segue you were like I
did move so Luke Skywalker by the way
hey at least I didn't start talking
about Batman that's true thank you for
not doing that Red Wave okay uh
Republicans now everybody's upset uh at
at these 10 Senators raising the debt
limit what like 400 billion or whatever
I don't know if the house voted yet I
was stuck on a plane without internet so
I'm sorry I'm low out of the loop uh
yeah thanks Lydia but uh yeah but we do
you think that I'll ask Luke first uh
Luke do you think that Mitch McConnell
uh next year if if the Senate regains uh
you know the Republicans regrained times
so I'm anyway do you think Mitch
McConnell will be the majority leader uh
I'm not sure
um I I don't think it even matters and
if he is it's just going to be another
lame duck session I think probably he
was just elected yeah yeah of course but
so but probably it's going to continue
on like it always has and the
Republicans are just going to turn over
and not really do much when that happens
who would you who would you guys like to
see
as the Senate Majority Leader Rand Paul
yes Rand Paul absolutely pretty much
okay I mean that's that's a pipe dream
that's never happened
I know it's never happened even a hard
question what's your second who's your
second choice oh Josh Hawley oh I don't
know Ted Cruz there you go
I don't care I yeah honestly honestly if
it's like uh Rand Paul's a Libertarian
remember how remember how we didn't like
Ted Cruz back in 2016. I remember that
and now he's awesome like I don't think
he's presidential I've I've actually
said in in one of my videos that I think
that he would be like the perfect
Supreme Court Justice oh interesting but
I don't think I don't see him as ever
becoming president of the United States
he's too he's too polarizing but he's a
really he's a really smart guy and he's
definitely won me over uh as far as
being a senator uh actually did you guys
see this the Shane Gillis
the the you know Shane Gillis he's the
he's the uh Saturday Night Live
uh guy he was he was brought on and then
he was yeah and then he was immediately
fired because of things that he said in
a podcast I've seen him he well he's he
has a stand-up special that's that he
put on YouTube and it's amazing and it's
really funny and he's totally like
ripping on Ted Cruz but in a funny way
and Trump and Biden and it's definitely
worth the watch but uh but yeah people
just didn't like Ted Cruz and then he
what however he did I don't know how he
did it but I like I love him not to vote
for him for president all right uh I I
think the Republican party is just
mostly garbage there's like a handful of
people that are good but I think like
Holly I I agree yes he's great cotton is
great yeah uh you know everybody loves
uh uh everybody loves Rand Paul so you
know uh I don't like that zodiac guy
um did you see he tweeted yeah I mean he
hired someone for his Twitter account
and they're doing a great job somebody
I'll be honest they discovered the
identity of the Zodiac Killer and then
Ted Cruz we did thank God I I don't no
no he wrote he wrote no no the there's
the there's a new investigation into who
the Zodiac Killer is and he wrote no
I don't like that though I mean yeah
it's an AOC Style politicking no I like
to I like that Ted Cruz is self-aware
and and totally kind of rolls with it
you know like he just doesn't care I
mean he's he's gotten more insults from
once you're in he threw a beard when
you're insulted by Donald Trump
like everything else kind of like pales
in comparison have you ever have you
ever seen bulworth yes so that's what
happened you know Ted Cruz up on stage
and Trump's just ran just railing him
and railing them and then he's like
sitting his apartment and he's like just
drinking the scotch on the bottle
laughing like
and then it decides just to wing it and
then if people end up liking him but I
don't getting back to the Zodiac thing I
don't like that I don't like that these
right I don't like that these people
actually came out and said it we think
it's this guy this guy's dead he can't
defend himself what are you talking
about well because you talked about
Zodiac Killer no I was talking about a
red wave no we but we Ted Cruz and
you're talking about come on we're
trying to put in the chat guys come on
don't you know back me I'm reading it
they're like we don't care
there's a delay okay there's
so you're saying the Zodiac Killers
could be the Senate Majority Leader yeah
yeah
sure
yeah I I or Mark Hamill
Luke Skywalker sure um yeah but Luke
died so he's a forced ghost uh so stupid
no I I there's 14 Democrat seats up 20
Republican seats up so I'm not sure the
Republicans even take it back even if
but I guess no no they will they will
I'll and I'll and I'll tell you who
exactly uh is for first of all it's 50
50 right now right right and and first
of all this doesn't even make any sense
to me Schumer is the majority leader
there's only there's you know how
there's 48 Democrats too independent yep
and 50 Republicans so technically the
original concern the majority at least
in party but uh weird it well what you
know fine yes the the independence they
they caucus with the Democrats and I
guess by default right but I uh Rafael
Warnock he's gone he he won special
election his term is up in 2022.
disguise a radical the only reason uh he
he shouldn't have actually
um uh what's his name the other guy uh
the guy that everybody thinks is cute
uh Donald Trump
no no uh the the other Senator he
basically
um John ossip yeah yeah see okay
in the election because they have this
because they have the uh the the you
have to have like 50 percent right uh so
nobody got 50 and that's why they had to
have the runoff if Doug Collins thanks
Doug Collins you jerk if Doug Collins
didn't run against uh Kelly Lefler
she would won but instead you know Trump
loses the election and you have all
these disaffected Republicans going male
and voting that doesn't work and and
then you have like morons like um the
woman you know Michael Flynn's lawyer
and they're like yeah yeah don't don't
go vote don't go vote and then and then
that he's unpopular he's he's gonna lose
he's gonna lose and it's very possible
that Mark Kelly's gonna lose too uh oh
so so so here we go here we go um when
the Republicans take back the house and
the Senate we will all be able to rise
up
you know light a cigarettes sit back
down and then do nothing yeah uh well I
I don't know if we're gonna get anything
done but I I guarantee that we'll it all
I only want is the firewall I don't want
the green new deal I don't want this
build back better BS
uh it's it's all the great reset see see
if Warnock and ossoff were not elected
we wouldn't be having this right now
Biden would just be in an incredibly
like he wouldn't even get anything done
through reconciliation right and it
would be amazing right and he's like oh
I wrote buildback better I wrote all
these things like yeah and we're not
looking at it we don't care like try in
2022. try 2024 and he's not running in
2024 he can't even talk the guy can't
even talk Biden Biden I wonder if
Biden's a patsy
no he's look he I don't know think about
it he he's been wanting he wanted to be
president right right but think about
how he's not there you know what I mean
and so the Democrats here's what happens
Donald Trump enacts a bunch of things
that work right the Remain the migrant
protection protocols you know uh um the
policies towards uh immigration in
general right
um deportations which brought jobs back
back to like these chicken plants the
tariffs yeah there's a trade War there
were a lot of problems but we saw auto
manufacturing coming back to Michigan
things like that the economy was doing
really well and the Democrats are like
okay we need to reverse these things but
if we do people are gonna get pissed and
then Joe Biden sitting in the corner
with his tongue hanging out and they're
like let's make him president for a term
make him do all this stuff and you know
what they do they instead of uh would it
be crazy if instead of like him actually
being in the White House they built like
a Sound Stage across the street just
like stuck him in it that would be so
and then have everyone be like look he's
the president like a fake White House
right and then and then they start
enacting all these policies that destroy
the good things Trump did and then you
know start wars botch Afghanistan punish
people who are anti-wars and troops into
Syria just really just go at kovitz
getting you know the the pandemic is not
getting any better the lockdowns are
getting worse and then it all is
absorbed by Joe Biden
who very heroically looks the Democrats
in the eyes and says I can be that hero
the one you deserve the one you need
he's definitely taken one for the
globalist I would say I mean every
single policy and I don't think they're
mistakes I don't think they're blunders
I don't think they're there's so much
money invested in them I mean everything
the president does is carefully uh
reviewed by a team of people he has a
whole bunch of PR experts down to the
tie down to the to the background every
little thing is carefully curated to
give off a specific image to give off a
specific idea to to manipulate the
general public I don't think a lot of
this is by accident I think they're
gonna blame a lot of the bull crap that
they never had the balls to push through
on the senile old man who's not really
there and I don't think Biden's really
there I don't think most presidents
really are there except for for some few
instances but for the vast majority of
presidents you could see the same
foreign policy you see the same
Financial policy you see the same
policies that over and over again
predominantly screw over the middle and
poor class and only enrich the
billionaire corporate class so so it's
just been the same thing over again just
just keep replacing him just keep just
keep blaming all in on him and to me
he's the perfect puppet it's the perfect
situation to rush through jam through
all the bull crap that no one even dared
to put a face behind just a few years
ago and then they'll they'll uh they'll
run Kamala no she's very unpopular I
mean she's I mean Biden's numbers are
down camelos were never up uh like she
was never polling High she never had a
favorable rating
comma I don't give a damn excuse me
whatever a camp what yeah
you know what I'm trying to say yeah so
so who then
what do you mean who if it's not going
to be Biden or or uh Kamala I don't
think it's gonna matter at that point I
think we're at such a stage where I
don't know I think we're I got an idea
Trump Jr Ron as a Democrat yes perfect
perfect plan it solves all the problems
Caitlyn Jenner
you know because that worked so well no
Andrew Yang in in the the forward party
yeah he's selling a book like don't
don't even you know this guy's 15
minutes or up screw him is it the four
war party word okay yeah yeah uh okay so
did he even like announce how different
he is like his major policy changes did
he even go into any of that he's so no
he he's just like you know not left
not right but what is he
like yeah a great great job it's like a
it's like an eight-year-old wrote it you
know yeah like he's okay going going
back to so Andrew Yang's not running
he's so uncharismatic like he's he's
never gonna win well he's trying to be
mayor of New York City yeah
he he did so great he's awful he's an
awful debater he's he's hey wait hey hey
how about this oh big pandemic right all
the all the robots are gonna
everything's gonna be automated now
really everybody's working from home and
then you have all the front line workers
and everybody in retail they're not
being replaced nobody's working
well but but they're not being replaced
by by Automation and and behind a lot of
that automation are people behind the
scenes right making food and then
shoving it in a hole where you click a
keypad and open a door and go oh it's
magic you know it's that's not how it
works he's not gonna he's like getting
getting back to uh who's gonna run who
can run for president in 2024 because
it's a Democrat it will not be Joe Biden
he it cannot be maybe who knows they
keep pulling them out
now yeah they'll get like a wheelchair
or something I'm like here you go yeah
good going mad I mean are they gonna
walk are they gonna like push them
around like Stephen Hawking and just
like saying Biden can't so we're gonna
have this computer talk it won't be a
big difference from what's Happening Now
have you guys seen The Onion article
stress of presidency already ages but in
10 years
[Laughter]
well okay it's not you're you're right
about about kamala's uh numbers numbers
yeah I think they're they're hovering
around like 49 if she was actually out
more people would just she's not she's
hiding she's the most amazing borders
are ever you know like she's she's not
gonna she she's so she's unpopular but
she's also not a genuine person and
she's not she's not charismatic at all
like there's there's nothing to her she
cackles at pain and suffering yeah like
that's that's a bad personality I mean I
mean who doesn't like right
or suffering you murdered children in
the Middle East a journalist is like a
journalist was literally like ma'am
human traffickers are abandoning
children in rivers they're dying and
children are being raped
man okay first of all chat while while
uh I'm pontificating her who do you
think could run in 2024 not Harris not
Biden as a Democrat I'm looking at the
chat right now so I'll be able to answer
question thank you very much it's very
they're saying Brandon everyone's saying
Brandon right now
that's like the greatest thing ever
I'm using that hashtag now I love it
it's amazing it's like uh you see what
Scott Adams said he said uh a slogan
idea for Trump 2024 his presidency is
Trump slogan
perfect and it's it's more fun to say
people are saying your mom Booker yeah
these nuts Hillary uh lots of brandons I
think Andrew Como AOC
I'm just reading off some of the results
Tulsi uh Tulsi a lot of brandons Joe
Rogan Newsom a lot of people are saying
Newsome um yeah Matthew McConaughey
Hunter Hunter Biden some people are
saying I don't Al Gore I don't think
knew somebody I think maybe Garcetti
maybe Newsome reminds me of like a
generic movie villain
you know like yeah like a generic movie
villain like probably like a sub boss
not the final boss but like the Arrogant
guy who ends up you know he reminds me
of you know in Iron Man 3 there's a guy
who's always chewing gum that guy like
not not in their attitudes and the way
they behave and the smugness and it's
like he's not the big bad boss he's just
like an underling but like a big
underling you know see that this is
you're right that he's smug he's
definitely a very smug person and I
think that's why a lot of these
popular
these popular politicians from certain
States just can't break out outside of
the borders of that state like say Chris
Christie Chris Christie was was kind of
popular in New Jersey he goes out on the
national stage and he's a dud uh Rudy
Giuliani America's mayor right like this
is this guy this guy was like leadership
Mr 911. and then stop talking about and
then he come yeah exactly but then he
comes out and it's like he and he's
basically just like a know-it-all New
Yorker people are also saying Michelle
Obama
um and Oprah yeah but we've already had
a black male president already so I I
think Michelle Obama would win I think
she'd be good I think she'd get a
massive Landslide
I'm going to repeat Bill Burr but like
why because she danced on Ellen yes yeah
exactly I think I'm kidding she she
she's Obama 2.0 and she's a woman and
she's gonna get all the women are going
to vote for her she's gonna get all of
the social justice vote plus there's
gonna be a lot of people who are like
Obama
I think Oprah too also has a big chance
because she kind of tested the waters
there were some news articles suggesting
that she might run for some kind of
office and they were kind of testing it
because pollsters usually do that they
usually they usually kind of put out
their candidate saying they might run
and they kind of field to test this
Oprah also had a lot of meetings with
Bloomberg with the Rockefellers with Mr
Bill Gates when they had their secret
meeting in New York City talking about
population reduction a few years ago so
she's in the Inner Circle of a lot of
ruling Elites she's in the Inner Circle
of like the Kissinger's the the
Rockefellers watch Childs the Gates's
they all met privately they all had
their secret meetings look up the
meeting that happened the media called
this the meeting of the superheroes and
this was a meeting that happened in New
York City and they talked about
literally population reduction and this
was about five to seven years ago and a
lot of people you know forget how
involved Oprah actually is in our
political Spectrum especially with the
money that she donates especially with
the culture remember when she was
pro-iraq war yeah and there was like
some guest was like I just don't think
that we should invade Iraq and then she
was like what you believe we should be
weak yeah I was like what holy freaking
cow I mean and she's perfect she she
knows how to cater to an audience she
knows how to read scripts she knows how
to push the globalist propaganda more
than anyone else she knows how to hold a
conversation how to debate people how to
argue with people she would be I I mean
I'm calling it Oprah 2024 uh I I
wouldn't be surprised not to see it at
some point or some kind of level of
because I mean we had Donald Trump he
was a reality TV star I don't think
we're gonna go away from this kind of
factor of entertainment and societal
impact being involved in politics I
think it's only going to increase as it
did in Idiocracy but how smart do you
think she is on on policy intelligence
really I mean she's she's a smart woman
obviously yeah yeah I mean she's what is
she she's a billionaire she's a part of
the billionaire club right doesn't make
you smart but it makes you she had the
right people around her but I would say
that's smart you know so I say I think
she is smart enough and uh and and I
think she definitely has the connections
so I I think there's you know something
to to think about that she got the money
to sell fun too and her running mate
would be the rock or somebody like you
saw the rock support
um Newsome and the uh recall election of
course he did well he supported Biden
too yeah yeah he came out anything for
money man that's all that's all that's
what it's all about who would if you had
to vote between one
one of these two choices you you had to
vote there's no out oh the rock hands
now the rock or Oprah
I would definitely vote for The Rock
just because I would never vote for a
woman I wouldn't vote for I wouldn't
vote for her
that's true I want to vote for friends
wow sexist I know I'm sorry I'm sorry
everyone sorry to disappoint everyone
no no no no no no no I wouldn't there
wouldn't be much difference in any of
them and I just I would just for jump
off uh no no you're just jumping off
it's like Highlander flip a coin because
it really won't matter because they'll
push the same policies
I'll flip a coin but who would be more
fun to see right right I think
when Oprah isn't
oh you get a cruise missile and you get
it and the rock is gonna be like who
wants a Hellfire missile so which one is
more fun you know I kind of think the
Oprah would be more fun because she's
like everybody gets Hell Fire missiles
everybody gets Medicare oh imagine this
you know we should we should make this
you know the scene in Iron Man when he
does the Jericho and the mountain
explodes what is this you and Iron Man
today yeah yeah always yeah so so when
he does the Jericho missile and he wipes
up the whole mountain behind him in the
first movie which needed Oprah being
like yeah that could be your campaign
for her presidency like that's the only
ad she'll need and she'll win my
favorite because of the pro war part one
of my favorite memes is that where she's
doing you know everybody gets the thing
and it's peace yeah
it's like it's like everyone's screaming
and running top top 100 favorite things
in the internet that's that's classic
classic stuff
[Music]
Oprah bees
oh my goodness everybody knows what I'm
talking about oh my goodness but most
importantly I still think we're very
long ways away from 2024 I think there's
going to be a lot of surprises a lot of
upheaval a lot of crazy things to come
up before then that will change
everything and we'll change our
Viewpoint of exactly how we see politics
well first of all we're going to have
you know the big game changer is going
to be like covet 23 that'll be I think
the economic big thing the economic
aspect will be more prevalent to be
honest we're going to have a covid
forever we're going to have like a new
covet every every election cycle it's
going to be perfect well there's no
reason to be a thing yeah a little bit
yeah
and the people are crying oh yeah and
the reaction from the crowd that's
that's what makes that that yeah it's
amazing everybody's freaking out
there's a woman crying
I I would do that then go for through
another four years of Joe Biden
you know thousands of bees you have a
choice you have to open a box full of
bees in your bedroom or former age of
Joe Biden well well there's also
speaking of bees there's also and and
memes there's also the Nicholas Cage
meme
where he's where he's he's got the thing
and you know from uh the Wicker man yeah
uh and and he's and he screwed a piece
like I would rather do that than go
through another four years of Joe Biden
uh probably but you know the problems
the Democrats had in the last cycle too
is they don't have anyone and I think
this is the biggest indicator that
Democrats and the left are completely
not cool and see and and the the list
that that uh that Luke was reading you
know he was saying you know Booker like
you know book Booker Booker was terrible
in the debates and he's not charismatic
either you know you know the interesting
thing is I don't know if cool is the
right word describe Trump but uh there's
something he has an IT Factor right
right right absolutely there's something
about there's something about him like
first of all he's funny and we all know
that whether you hate his policies like
oh it's like when when he was talking
about the definition of what woke is
you know and which I'm not going to
repeat here but I was hilarious it was
so funny it was so funny when he was
saying I I know the moment he won it's
when Megan Kelly said you know you
insulted Rosie O'Donnell I don't know
you called women fat pigs only Rosie
O'Donnell and I was like and the crowd
erupted yeah and the crowd was like
and they laughed all of them laughed
they weren't supposed to you have to see
you have to watch this Shane Gillis
thing I'm telling you it's really funny
he points out uh that those debates the
Republican debates they were electric
they were they were absolutely they were
must see TV because there's there's
something about like Gillis points out
he's like you know you have like a
policy guide like blah blah blah you
know that I I like schools and this and
that and Trump's dislike insulting
people left and right you're just like
yeah do it man it's like you know shut
up but it's not that it's it's that that
anger people felt where it's like the
Republicans don't do anything they waste
everyone's time they had power in 2016
1780 they did literally nothing Trump
getting in there and insulting them just
felt good he gets in and he gave up it
was like they hired a guy to go middle
give everybody the middle finger and
they were happy with that
I mean obviously they were they were
happy they wanted a lot more they wanted
a lot of what Trump was offering and
with I'm saying they were satisfied
watching Trump give the middle finger to
these people and within a couple weeks
like even I think even before the first
debate Trump was leading in the polls I
I think so right like it they were
they're like oh well he was really like
no no he wasn't like you you need to
look at the actual like go to go to RCP
you know there was like one week where
Ben Carson was like leading the polls
and it was by like a fraction and then
then he just kind of sputtered out too
in the weirdest housing pick a housing
department pick ever but you know he he
there's totally flame out but there's no
there's no Democrat personalities that
have any Charisma no none no it's
definitely not Harris definitely not
Biden but because they can't have
Charisma a name name name name uh a borg
unit with Charisma you know what I mean
like they're they're none they're just
cookie cutter garbage but there are some
there are some like like well Bernie's
not a Democrat but Bernie had there's
something about Bernie Sanders there
there's he has a certain Christian even
though it gets old because it's just the
same thing over in the the billionaires
and the Millionaires and you know and
you're you know like you've said in the
past he stopped saying millionaires he
became a millionaire her he's like he
looked he started saying it again I
wonder if his bank account went down
he's like it's safe to criticize the
millions again I'm not a millionaire
anymore but there's there's some there's
something to Bernie Sanders
and and it's the weirdest thing because
I remember working in news and covering
uh 2016 and you're just like
like you you thought it was a joke like
nobody ever heard of this guy right most
people you know and you're you're almost
like well he's doing it as a public
service he's going in and he's raising
some issues he's saying hey we can we
you know we can get free college for
people we can you know we can help the
middle class we can do all these things
and and you're like he's he's gonna
bring up a couple things they're gonna
have six debates and and Hillary's gonna
win but you have this guy and he doesn't
he knows he's not gonna win and then it
got to his head then he's like oh man I
could win this I could win that I could
win it all and and then he lost because
you know everything's good forfeits and
bows down and kisses the ring of power
of Hillary one of my favorite moments is
is or one of the saddest moments is
during the the 2016 Democrat convention
I was there and I think you were there
too when he's oh yeah
like this you know they had they had
special
um noise canceling uh subwoofers that
they brought in to cancel out the Bernie
people inside of that Stadium um and
another thing to to really consider I
wanted to comment on that yeah go ahead
so you're mentioning you know uh you
know Bernie giving in selling out and
all the stuff and when I look at AOC and
a lot she shifted a whole lot as now
this you know as she's trying to stay in
they were gonna they were gonna take
away her her District they were going to
redistrict and get rid of her they were
going to primary her and then all of a
sudden her she started shifting a little
bit more we just saw Pelosi walk up to
her and wave her arms in the air on
C-Span and then AOC changes her vote on
the Iron Dome from no no no no let me I
made a video about this and and if you
really have to zoom in on that footage
she ignored AOC Pelosi ignored AOC
Pelosi I can't remember the names but
Pelosi was speaking to two other uh
Congress people
having a conversation and she Pelosi
does that thing with their hands anyway
right then uh
all these people came like Rasheeda not
Rashida Tilly uh pramila jayapal and uh
Debbie Dingle and AFC they all came to
that little area where they're where
Pelosi's having this conversation and
aoc's like putting on a show and she's
like putting her hands in her it's like
she's so sad and Pelosi's just
completely focused like she's wearing
blinders she's completely focused on
these two Congress people but but wait
this is the best part she looks over for
like a second and keeps talking like she
she does this power move she wasn't
reacting to AOC right yes he did not
change her vote I don't know why AOC
changed her vote right that's what
that's what I'm saying uh irrelevant the
fact is one of the first things that
happened with AOC when she got elected
was all of a sudden her really strong
opinions on Palestine shifted a bit when
she was on PBS and says you know
honestly I don't know all that much and
she got roasted by the left who said
you're we're gonna see more of this AOC
certainly is a leftist and a socialist
but she's trying to tell that lines she
doesn't lose her District and Bernie
Sanders did the exact same thing Bernie
Sanders I'll tell you what my opinion of
both of these people are Bernie well
he's in a gym with this 20 Banner he
gets put up for his presidential run and
no one cares no one's ever cared but all
of a sudden he's getting a Groundswell
of support eventually he's famous you
know it was very very quickly all of a
sudden he's feeling it he's feeling it
that feeling of of flying so high and
then Bernie realizes the Democrats
aren't going to let him go anywhere with
this they're going to shut him down and
he needs to play ball or he'll lose it
all and so Bernie said I will play ball
he stops saying the millionaires the
moment see Bernie was standing outside
the Billionaire's mansion with all of
the people behind him yelling with
pitchforks and he's like I could see the
keyhole the billionaires and the
billionaires are inside and then they
open the window and say Hey Bernie we
want to come in absolutely and then he
comes inside goes all of you have to go
home or we're calling the cops that
that's Bernie Sanders that's AOC yeah
he's a grifter he had some personality
he had some Charisma but he totally sold
out on many times on on many instances
and another thing about the personality
and Charisma you don't need it we just
saw through the latest presidential
election you don't even need a candidate
you need someone in the basement you
don't need anyone out there in the
campaign Trail you don't need anyone on
the television you don't need anyone
doing interviews you literally have an
image of someone which they have of
Biden so why wouldn't they just repeat
the same thing I mean the media controls
reality for a large swap of people and
that reality was was conveyed the power
of the media was really perfectly
represented through the last election
where a candidate didn't even run hold
on hold on and we have the article from
the Atlantic stay alive Joe Biden
Democrats need little from the front
runner Beyond his corporeal presence
Bernie
Bernie's biggest mistake in 2020. was
running as a Democrat
he's not a Democrat he is an independent
right
the Democratic party basically screwed
him over in 2016.
then at one point he's leading into
polls he was leading in the polls he
almost became the president and then
everyone freaked out the DNC all the
other candidates up on that stage the
media everybody and they went after him
and within two weeks he was done as soon
as South Carolina happened
he should have never run as a Democrat
because he ran independent Trump would
have won he keeps he keeps saying he
keeps saying I have we have the largest
Grassroots organization we have the
largest Grassroots organization better
thank you twenty dollars
I am asking you again
what's a good asking you
to give all your money to me he could
have Bernie Sanders he could have run as
a Democrat he would have gotten
he would have gotten a ton of
he basically he could have he could have
actually debated Trump and Biden think
about how amazing that would have been
he didn't need the Democrats but instead
he was just like he and he goes and I
promise that I will uh I I will get
behind uh the nominee he didn't want to
do that he didn't want to get behind
Biden but he had to well you know
because he wants to keep his money the
only the only reason that he he became a
he ran as a Democrat for a second time
[ __ ] is because he he wanted that uh he
wanted that national attention to be up
on stage again
but he didn't have anything new to say
and instead all these other candidates
like uh Castro Elizabeth Warren all
these people they just they just
basically co-opted a whole bunch of his
ideas and he just saturated everything
now Bernie isn't like he he wasn't like
a special person everybody on that stage
was was talking about the things that
you know free college and immigration
and all these things and he screwed it
for me he screwed himself over he tried
one up one-upping everyone else being
like remember back when I said we have
to have secure borders I didn't mean it
I am not a bigot we should have
completely open borders and uh we can
bring in everybody I loved it when the
world socialist website called Bernie
Sanders a nationalist capitalist no no
yeah the world's because he's he was
speaking at a rally and someone said you
know should we allow all the refugees to
come in open the borders and he went no
no Heavens no if we open the borders
everyone in the world would want to come
here he talked about it being a Koch
brother plan trying to get free labor
inside of the United it states to
compete with the American labor force
which again no one even talks about
anymore which is crazy he was making
some good points but I think he played
his role he did I don't think he was an
idiot I think he did exactly what they
told him to do he said yes master tell
me what to do and he did it exactly like
they wanted him to do it he shouldn't
have he injected he injected a whole
bunch of energy into the Democratic
party he got a whole bunch of money he
got a whole bunch of people young people
predominantly interested in the party
that were never interested some of them
tried to Rebel but he came on that
National stage and he bowed down to
Hillary he said okay everyone put all of
your power all of your energy everything
you have sacrificed for me give it to
Hillary I'll I'll tell you I'll tell you
I remember exactly what happened Bernie
Sanders was standing before this large
activist base Point who was in Seattle
who are pointing their lightsaber at
Hillary who's on the ground going I'm
too weak and then Bernie was like you
don't don't do it I need her to win I I
need her and then the people were like
no Hillary is wrong and Evil and then
Bernie's sabered off the the populist
left the saber and then Hillary forced
lightning him out the window and then
buddy and then he fell to his knees and
Hillary Clinton walked over to him and
she was like why is my Bernie Sanders
and Bernie was like I will do whatever
you say and that's how we got Darth
Sanders I thought you were I'm sorry I
thought you were gonna you were gonna
refer to the Seattle uh rally remember
when the Black lives matter oh yeah
basically just just he just gave up and
started calling the uh wow and started
calling the crowd racist and they were
in a crowd just like what do you want
how dare you how dare you Bernie Bernie
needed the Democratic party to lift him
up and I I think genuinely that Bernie
was like I will use the Democratic party
that's why he ran as a Democrat it was
the only way he was going to get a
pedestal and he had to play ball and
that meant he had to change his
positions and he probably thought but by
one time president I'll do the right
thing and it's never going to happen and
then once they made him Rich he was like
well I I deserve it I've I've fought my
whole life and so now he's got what how
many houses does a guy own uh three
houses in the summer camp he said right
hey Bravo you know being a socialist
pays off I guess I mean for the wealthy
Elite ones for the poor people they tend
to starve or die but you know in this
capacity everybody who voted for these
Democrats I tell you man I mentioned
this before my friends people I know my
whole life were like you're so dumb
Trump's an idiot Biden's the best and
now they're going like my job's gonna
fire me if I don't get this vaccine but
my doctor's saying like I shouldn't do
it what do I do and I'm like
I'm like you're coming to me for advice
now wow I'm impressed why don't you ask
Joe Biden why don't you ask him ask him
what he thinks Joe Biden is gloating
that I'm losing my job well bend the
knee bro you wanted it but but Trump is
the fascist oh I remember when Trump
deployed the military to deal with
antifa riders burning down buildings and
killing people oh wait he didn't do that
I will I will say though it was uh I
think was it Bill Barr who went and
killed that got that antifa guy
you know what I'm talking about the guy
who shot Aaron Danielson barred
dispatched feds and they went found the
guy and he's in his car and said a
shootout happened and they killed him
hey uh Lydia yes
you uh you sent me a link earlier uh do
you want to talk about that real quick
which one is that yeah uh Wisconsin
right yeah so we were talking a little
bit about Wisconsin so one of the things
that comes up that has come up is that
um Kyle I don't want to get us in
trouble but Kyle rittenhouse's lawyers
have talked about how he was shouldn't
have been in trouble because he uh
he was following some of the hunting
protocols there in Wisconsin oh yeah so
he was allowed to carry a gun and
everyone's like oh you know humans are
animals and it's like well but also and
then Jacob Lake yeah we have this from
NBC News hunting laws allowed Cal
Rittenhouse to carry weapon during fatal
shootings in Wisconsin lawyers say I
mean that's that's the gist of it
lawyers say well sure sure but I'm
pretty sure they're correct because
we've gone over this numerous times
about the statutes and whether you're
allowed to carry open or not and he
didn't have a handgun he had a long gun
which typically I regulated less and so
I'm pretty sure we had someone come out
like no no here's the statue here's the
law and they're like he was allowed to
carry the weapon
see I I think that they I think
eventually they're going to have a this
this I think they're gonna end up trying
to throw it out I think yeah I think
afterwards there's probably going to be
like Merrick Garland will probably come
out and say we need to have a an
investigation like they did with Michael
Brown and then they'll do it and they
and they won't be able to do anything
about it so initially I was saying I
thought Rittenhouse will get life but
then the judge seems to have come out
very much like yeah F off to the BS
media when they were like he did the
okay hand gesture a white power hand
gesture and the judge was like what are
you talking about that's not true he's
like I've never heard of that yeah are
you lying to me and then they were like
oh but the ADL says and he was like I
have no idea what you're talking about
that's ridiculous yeah so then people
were like whoa this judge is like not
having it but you're right I think what
will happen is now I'm kind of leaning
towards Kyle might actually win and then
Merrick Garland comes in with this oh
yeah well well uh what the link that
Lydia sent me earlier was that the
Department of Justice isn't going to
charge the police officer that shot uh
Jacob right as they should there should
never be a charge Jacob Blake is the is
the rapist correct no no he's the hero
remember that you know
he's the guy
basically said he's the guy he's the guy
who sexually assaulted that woman in her
bed yeah and then when the cop tried to
stop him from escaping and kidnapping
some children he grabbed the knife and
then the cops shot him that that's what
we're talking about right yes the hero
the hero yes I remember a bunch of NFL
players put the the they put the
stickers saying they support rape on
their on their helmets
oh my God that's true I mean it did
technically it did yeah but but the
Department of Justice they they know and
he even and and I think the big thing
was he was on it was either Robin
Roberts or Gail King uh he basically
said well yeah I had a knife and you're
just like
um that's it Case Closed sir yeah I
don't know who these players are but
here's like here's a guy and he is
throwing the ball and he has a sticker
on his helmet that says he supports rape
that's great and then here's uh I think
here's another guy I don't know these
quarterbacks uh stick around there how
much expressing their support for rape
oh all of these guys wow what team is
that New Orleans this one New Orleans
the New Orleans rapists I guess it's
like I don't I don't know anything about
football to be honest but um you know a
bunch of players came out in support of
rape good for them yeah I guess and and
look you know you can come to me and
tell me but Tim surely you must
understand they didn't know that and
I'll be like so you mean to tell me
these guys didn't know anything about
what happened in in Wisconsin with Jacob
Blake and they're supporting him anyway
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm not going to
make that assumption because that makes
too many too much of an assumption I'm
gonna go ahead and say they're
supporting Jacob Blake because they know
the story which means they support rape
and and I'm sure that the same thing
happened with uh the WNBA
too weren't they didn't they have like
little you know like probably Jacob
Blake stickers on there under five
dollar uniforms I really feel like all
of them just heard the story of this
poor prosecuted persecuted oh yeah they
did yeah oh my gosh the WNBA created a
shirt with bullets in it in support of
rape good for them good for them I mean
in support of a rapist sorry oh okay
oh you know you're right you're right it
was it was it was it was sexual assault
he sexually assaulted potato potato we
got to be clear on this because these
are the people that come out and claim
that they fight for women that they
fight women's rights and all of these
these these these individuals are
calling Kyle Rittenhouse a kid who
worked the y a terrorist for trying to
defend his community after a
seven-year-old man was was bashed over
the back of the head and left bloody and
bleeding on the ground by a bunch of
rioters and he put the reason they
attacked him was because he put a fire
out in a dumpster they were pushing
towards a gas station we've had what
four or five witnesses come out with the
show with video evidence proving that
was the case yeah and then he fled when
they attacked him Jacob Blake went into
a woman's home and assaulted her
sexually and then tried kidnapping her
children and they wear his name and call
Kyle written as the terrorist
Malcolm X once said the media is the
most powerful entity on Earth they have
the power to make the innocent guilty
and to make the guilty innocent and
that's power because they control the
minds of the masses he's correct all
right what would you rather what would
you rather have to endure all right
uh-oh
um
having to attend every single
game
uh season you know having like season
tickets to you're the W favorite WNBA
team um
or four more years of Joe Biden oh
hold on listen listen wait I can take
one for the team what I can take one for
America what do you think me having to
endure WNBA games means no one else has
to endure Joe Biden yeah
yeah okay four more years of Joe Biden
affects everyone having to go to a WNBA
game just just affects me that's true I
can be that hero the hero that we need
so you support Kamala Harris to be
president of the United States is that
who said that who else is going to be
president if it's not Biden uh well
that's not the point who the president
Oprah Oprah I don't think it matters
I'll I'll take Biden as president
hold on how do they stop Joe Biden from
running they can't he never ran in the
first place I don't think he's there I
think he's like literally he's in a
digital soundstage across the street
here's why else what's happening they
might be using Holograms at this point
I'm not even beyond that I no I I seem
to recall that on on this very
amazing live stream
back in the day back in in the within
the past year
I said
that if Joe Biden's elected that you'll
never see him again I was so wrong I was
so on I was so wrong because I thought
well there's no there's no way he's
gonna he's gonna be you know
broadcasting maybe like once a month out
of a bunker right
he's on TV he's doing events Monday
through Friday
like on the regular
and it's almost like they're trying to
prove like his staff are trying to prove
that he's like still alive you know like
they're just like no see he's he's
standing in front of the camera guy
Sound Stage yeah that's weird that's so
weird Philip Wegman who's uh one of the
correspondents uh from you know he's
from Real Clear Politics
um he basically said that the seating in
that Auditorium is more comfortable
basically but for who the media yeah for
the media right media is running but
here's the thing and and the the last
when uh okay so for for those of you who
are not following just just to clarify
um the white house across the street
they built a a fake set for Joe Biden
it's it's bright it's it's TV lit there
there's uh there's all these windows
they're not Windows there's TV but
there's flat screens behind right right
to make it look like there's windows and
it says I mean but it it looks fake it
doesn't look like the White House right
uh but it's it's like a theater State
it's like a theater exactly and it's
perfect representation of exactly how
politics is theater right it's you know
it's all a show it's just like right
exactly so what they do they they made
the set and the last time that they had
an event it was it was about the debt
ceiling and Joe Biden has like a bunch
of virtual people he's talking to first
of all this thing doesn't even need to
be televised it doesn't need to be
broadcasted anywhere so boring who is
watching this nobody is watching this in
the first place right they might get a
sound bite out of it for the news but
nobody's like sitting there and glued to
their screen and going man I gotta I
Gotta See This I Gotta See Joe Biden
talk about the debt limit for an hour
like nobody cares right but in the
window it showed like that there there
were Flowers In Bloom in the Rose Garden
which I don't think in this time of year
that they they are sure I thought I
thought the word fall was a signal of
like the pedals in merging yeah to fall
but people pointed this out and they're
like why did they build a fake White
House and it's like uh yeah exactly like
why did they do this uh I mean it is TV
ready and it looks fine I guess but
these events that Biden does in there
like no nobody's watching it people are
going to the YouTube channel clicking
thumbs down and watching Tim cast like
that that's it they're not watching
they're they're not sitting there no I'm
serious nobody's watching this stuff and
then Biden he they they think that this
is like good for his image putting him
out every day and and you saw you saw
the tape from yesterday where he's
reading a bunch of names
and he can't read these names and he's
spelling he's trying to spell names and
it's just like like this is why people
think he's incompetent this is why his
like put bring him out like like twice a
week Trump didn't do events every single
day he spoke to depressed like on the
way to helicopter right to the Press
Gaggle that's it he didn't and maybe
with kovid he did he did he was out like
every day and eventually he was just
like I'll let Mike Pence deal with it he
didn't do an event every single day Joe
Biden doesn't need to do that and he's
out there every day and he just looks he
just he's just a crazy person it proves
that he's spry they're trying to say hey
he's alive guys trust me he's he's okay
well because here's what's going to
happen here's I guarantee this here's
what's going to happen
there's going to be a week where you
don't see them and people are going to
go is Joe Biden dead like people are
going to be like ridiculously worried
they're like where's Joe Biden he hasn't
done he hasn't done a press thing in a
week where is he is his health okay and
you're and and then you're gonna see him
walking from the helicopter with a cane
and he's gonna stumble forward
somersault and spring up and go hey
you're gonna walk over and be like you
thought I was gone and then he's gonna
go to and then he's gonna go to Kamala
Harrison going it was it was is always
you the Chocolate Factory is yours yes
he points in the white house but they
don't have many options though I mean if
you really think about it he can't talk
to the Press he can't take a question he
keeps talking about how he's ordered not
to talk to the media not I'm going to
get in trouble so what else are they
going to do hold on hold on he's told he
says this over and over again I'm going
to get in trouble if I talk I can't talk
to the Press he's also not in the White
House yeah what's going on
and then and then they they totally
Usher the press out like there there I
it was some somewhere in September I
don't know where it was I saw it on like
the news junkies channel on um on
YouTube
where he's he's talking about batteries
right like some per charging station and
he starts talking about a map and he
just starts kind of kind of going and
then suddenly the the his press people
are like okay let's go everybody like
he's he's starting to ramble and you
can't see this now you're not allowed to
see this because the president's going
on a thing there's a bunch of incidents
where they're doing live streams and
then he's like oh you have a question
and then the camera just cuts off and
they did and they did that the other day
they did this in in Michigan first of
all he he's out in Michigan and there's
nobody there there's like 10 people
there right none of them are masks it
says it's like Whitmer and I think
Debbie Dingle who was actually wearing a
mask for some reason nobody's wearing a
mask in the audience
Biden comes out with some union guy
looking out
the mask off because he's in front of
the camera right he does his little
speech
and then he goes he starts going to talk
to people
without a mask and then the White House
fee just quickly shut off right and then
and at one point and this is really
funny he goes he goes most of you in
this room and he's outside most of you
in this room can tell tell me where like
the most dangerous intersection in your
town is you're like he goes in this room
like whoever wrote that speech forgot
that nobody was there you know that he
was it was going to be an outside event
right you know because rooms are inside
so it and and all of his speeches are
the same it's all the copy It's All Copy
pasted I think I think have you seen
Stargate sg1
no but I mean I I saw the movie so in
the show and and all the good fans will
know this reference when the toe land
are occupied by the goal because their
plasma cannon stop working against their
Shields I mean this is very important
information basically it's an episode
where the uh you know you you know what
the show is about they have a Stargate
there's a planet that's very highly
Advanced they go there and everyone's
acting weird the government seems to be
acting strange records seem to be
missing and then it turns out it's
because they were secretly invaded and
no one on the planet knew and then the
plan ends up getting destroyed the point
I'm making is
something is telling Joe Biden what to
do it's probably aliens
are you saying Ryan and Jake Sullivan
are aliens because I believe it I'd
believe it hey Tony blinken Anthony
blinken is a an alien that proves it I
mean that that's proof okay as soon as
you mention them I'm like oh I'm kidding
no but but it's obvious that Joe Biden
may be the president in title but he's
he's something else is happening here
he's right there he's absolutely not
there most of the time when you talk to
him you could even see him in his eyes I
mean the guy has two metal stints in his
brain to hold holding back Major what is
aneurysms Robo Biden
um I think robobiden would be a just
slightly more competent it would be
pretty awesome yeah I mean like it's a
binary comes out rips his face off and
it's like a terminator and he's like ask
your question okay I I look I fine I
would vote for robo buying I would I do
first robot in you know in the White
House sure you know I fine I do that
robot fighting robot that's very diverse
yeah I like that yeah a first robot
president no I don't know what's going
on the first CIS white male robot
president yes no he's a Terminator
first Terminator president the first
Terminator yeah ask your question human
do you think I have a question about the
foreign policy enacted when you fired
all of our nuclear Arsenal at China and
Russia wiping them off the planet uh do
you think that's going to cost the
taxpayers
resistance is futile
this quote from Stargate sj1
yep uh we're under an alien occupation
that that proves it we're screwed no all
serious the snow in all seriousness Joe
Biden's not a robot that's what Tim's
trying to say no I'm saying that he is
the corporeal form they wished for in
order to defeat Trump the media ran and
now there's he's clearly not in charge
and I know it's kind of like maybe being
a dead horse to say but he's not in
charge of his own capacity but we need
to ask who is then and like why if he's
not in the White House who is the
multinational corporate billionaire
Clash like they always have been
Bill Gates and like Elon Musk I don't
know Jeff Bezos are in the Oval Office
and they're like it's they're mucking up
the place it's Obama it goes as high as
Obama yeah and then and then Susan Rice
Ron Clane
blinken Sullivan and then maybe Pelosi
Obama even previously talked about I
forgot exactly what source I think he
was talking to a later it was an
interview host where he talked about how
he wished he could do the whole thing
again but he wouldn't be the front front
person that he could be the person
behind the scenes yeah kind of like a
third term Obama's purposefully tanking
the country
no but he's pushing the agenda which
clearly don't help out the middle class
clearly don't help out the poor clearly
pushes a direct agenda that is counter
uh the American people counter American
culture and is pushing this larger kind
of horrible policies that they always
wished that they wanted to push and
approve but but never had the gold do it
so if you really do think about it that
way as far as the kind of sinister
motives to blame an old senile
geriatrics guy for doing all this this
is the perfect situation to do it but
here's here's the thing that gets me all
of these policies everything is failing
everything it's not fair it's benefiting
a lot of people and hurting everyone
else
it's benefiting his inner circle it's
benefiting the special interest it's
benefiting the military-industrial
complex it's benefiting the people who
have the most to gain here and while
everyone else is clearly losing so I
don't think I don't think it's done by
accident I think the reason you know
there's more people who died of of covid
this year than all of last year combined
this year we have more intervention than
we ever had more government than we ever
had I don't think I don't think that's
an accident that's my own personal
opinion uh my own personal perspective
from how I've been seeing politics for
the last 15 years it's always completely
backwards it's always counter-intuitive
and it never works to help out the
middle uh average American never I I
just want a robo-bite in 2024 t-shirt
that sounds good yeah right yeah we
shouldn't make that Robo Biden yes and
it'll just be like a Biden but like half
his face is like a Terminator face
and like his metal teeth yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna have to think about that what
would it be like that
Biden Harris font and everything and you
know say uh no it's gonna be cool
because Robo binding is brutal Robo
Biden is not biting all right fine fine
then who
who would Robo Biden's vice presidential
pick be oh that's tough because it can't
be Robo Harris no I mean she's a robot
but not that not like the good robot
right uh I don't know she's got the bug
with the with the laugh generic lizard
person yeah
robo-biting lizard person 2024 asteroid
yes
Robo Biden riding the asteroid towards
the Earth yes
yes hey speaking of asteroid by the way
not it has nothing to do with my merch
uh
I heard that there was some kind of uh
asteroid that potentially had minerals
on it like like gold and stuff that
could actually be mined and then
basically like whatever country goes and
claims it and mindset basically they
could just say hey um that's paid off
you know with all these with all these
minerals and and everything is that's on
this thing I think you guys heard about
that I was thinking about it earlier on
the plane where I had nothing to do with
no internet and I was thinking that that
would just kind of be like a godsend
where you could just say hey you know
let's let's instead of mincing a
trillion dollars
no well but but instead you could be
like hey look look what we did we sent
Bruce Willis and and Ben Affleck up to
uh mine this this uh asteroid and and
are they saying anything Luke
um I I I would get in trouble if I would
read half of the comments that people
are commenting you're a liar look at the
comment section I love the comment
section it's some of the most I
literally just I was just like I might
not even have to be able to show this
because I might think you guys in
trouble but uh I like reading the
comments I I enjoy it very much uh and
uh you guys are extremely entertaining
very fun even when you uh bust my chops
I appreciate it very much I don't
remember what I bought so so uh I owe
Andrew seven dollars for one uh when he
bought I let he lent me money for Subway
I just paid him back oh snap
bucks
wonderful you're rich Andrew I'm rich
beyond our wildest dreams while we were
here we're gonna auction that off fight
while we were here I formed the um the
timcast Federal Reserve oh cool you know
good to know we we just it's a
quantitative who is your treasury
secretary
yeah oh yeah but but you're paid back
[Laughter]
you think that the country is going to
break apart fall apart into a million
pieces and I hope so wow do you really
hope so
I'm so tired
oh well you know I the Civil War sure I
think that's coming
that was like the most like assertive
we've heard people talk about it yeah oh
yeah definitely yeah but uh I don't but
I don't think the country's gonna break
apart into 50
pieces you know 50 I I don't imagine the
country of Delaware they would be like
we have no food we have crabs huh that's
Delaware's Microsoft we got Joe Biden
all of these Joe Biden's their biggest
commodity here's the thing about the
union breaking apart it is going to be
the the Northeast that suffers the most
because the states are so tiny because I
mean New Hampshire people are going to
be like we good but Delaware Delaware's
in trouble Delaware is like one-fourth
of an existing state you know that's a
state that's like Delaware is like a
little piece cut off well the the only
and I don't even know if it if it
applies so much anymore but it's all
these companies are Incorporated there
right all these Financial companies
right but a lot of them are also moving
to uh I believe it's South Dakota or
North Dakota really it's somewhere it's
somewhere else in the country and and
it's almost like they Delaware had that
Niche for a long time and then other
states were like hey let's just rip off
Delaware you know why not so you know
what I I was thinking like when it comes
to all this chaos and stuff I just you
got to look to the people that are
leaders you know that are influencers in
you know Global governance and corporate
you know corporations and do what they
do so uh you know I look at Bill Gates
buying up Farmland buying up all the
Farmland more Farmland than anyone else
and I have to wonder like I wonder why
he's buying up all the farmland
might there be something that is to
occur that would make his Farmland very
valuable all right well I'll buy some
Farmland you know I'm not going to be
left I'm not going to be left holding
the holding an empty bag you know what
I'm saying are you are you also uh
making your stock picks like you know
are you following that that pelosis
thing oh is that what it is yeah well
there's entire like there's entire
careers made on Tick Tock of people just
following Nancy Pelosi's stock picks
they call her they call her the stock
market whale I mean Nancy Pelosi has
what is it like over a hundred million
dollars a lot of that money came from
the stock market that she is supposedly
regulating yes but but still there there
has to be something said about someone
being worth over a hundred million
dollars and then getting the stock picks
so right all the time coincidentally and
and literally people on Tick Tock are
making their entire careers just copying
her moves and saying you know this is
what you should do in the stock market
so you know it's only insider trading
when Republicans do it right uh there
was a whole big thing with with Leffler
with Kelly Lefler when they were saying
oh she yeah she benefited like everybody
benefited but we have to understand and
during the at the beginning of the
pandemic how crazy this insider trading
is it's not just with Nancy Pelosi it
was right before covid right before
covet some senators were caught up even
before 9 11 some senators were caught up
in insider trading uh before Wars a lot
of senators and congressmen know
something's going to happen and they
invest in particular military-industrial
complex stocks I mean there's a lot of
shady activity in the stock market well
I know your answer I I'm gonna let you
answer it though but do you do you think
that uh people in Congress should uh not
be able to do anything in the stock
market uh yeah of course of course while
they're while they're in while they're
in office yeah of course but what but
what if it's somebody like it's a
you know it's it's a a manager who's
doing it and they're not and and you
can't prove they'll find another way to
get somebody else to do it or their
grandchildren you heard about my
political philosophy uh uh marsism right
so here's how it works when when someone
runs for congress you know we we do it
as we normally do everybody runs they
vote then you'll get your winner they
all make their way to DC where then
they'll board a special uh a series of
private planes down to Florida where we
we get them onto a a rocket ship that
goes to Mars
yes
yes
no that's it yeah they go to Mars that's
it that's where the plan ends that's um
great great plan great plan solid
nothing else they're just gone
yeah oh but but I also did say like you
know because because we thought that was
going somewhere no to Mars yeah that's
it literally going to Mars Andrew shut
that goodbye uh politician no but but uh
but I can't remember who had on the show
but then someone brought up an
interesting point and they were like it
would be interesting how they would
legislate from things they would never
benefit from
like actually going to Mars they would
have no opportunity to benefit from any
of the policies they enact or any
insider trading or anything like that
they literally have to just
I don't know either be the Joker or
Batman
are we talking about Batman no okay
but but my thing but what if what if our
elected leaders were just you know
isolated underground and they could
never come out and they'd wear jumpsuits
since I get to choose to do something
you know very serious
no more insight of training no more
bribes no more no no no none of the
worries no more salary increases if you
want to serve the public you are
stripped of of all your access other
than doing your job but a big a big
problem with uh getting politicians to
divest from from all of their Holdings
is that that comes into question you
know are they are they selling are they
selling this off at this price because
of corruption or because well you know
that that's one of the reasons why Trump
couldn't just get rid of all of his
assets when he became president right he
was basically like well I'd be
investigated forever because they were
going they would have to look at they
would look at every single thing and go
Trump sold this building for this price
because right right oh well you know
every Trump isn't on like the the top
400 Forbes people and like who cares
wait no he is no I think I think in this
this year like he was like he's off that
list really yeah and it's like because
his whole he didn't he didn't become
president to get rich yeah no he lost a
lot he lost yeah he I mean he was huge
rap He sacrificed everything when was
the last time a rapper rapped about him
other than oh and maybe Lil Wayne you
know in a good way in a good way yeah so
anyway oh hey here
in question here's a weird question
speaking of presidents of all the guests
that you've had on this live stream
and not including us because that's just
Cheating Who and and this goes for you
chat who do you think who would you like
to see run for president out of all of
the guests that you've ever had
on on this oh me Alex Jones
I I I just would love the entertainment
value of it you know
um we've had we've had
could you imagine if like I could not
Alex Jones runs the Republican wins the
primary is put in the debate against
some Democrats
it's like it's like sometimes it's like
Trump's times ten when Trump was like
only Rosie O'Donnell Alex people you got
these people these lizards are these
dirty interdimensional beings it would
be amazing that'd be great yeah
do you concur I entirely concur I think
that Alex Jones should run for every
conceivable office fine honestly fine
Alex Jones for president that's right
you know I gotta say this I gotta say
this week's looks like it doesn't matter
who's President it doesn't matter
they'll be taken over by the globalists
Alex Jones
was right about so much that no one
believed him so much we every every time
we've had him on he says something we go
that's not true he was on he was on he
was on and like the we're talking about
like uh the Democrats in Congress are
proposing a new bill and then Alex Goes
George Washington wrote a letter about
the Illuminati saying that Thomas
Jefferson was in charge and I was like
wait what what have we even talk and
then he was like Google it and I was
like okay and I did from the Library of
Congress George Washington's letter
condemning the Illuminati and I'm like
oh geez he's right
it's like what if the only true religion
was Alex Jones's world view and we're
all wrong I'm scared imagine what all
that power would do to this head holy
cow I would say I mean a lot of people
in the comment section are saying Alex a
lot of people are also saying Dave Smith
since you know he is running for for
President Michael malice press secretary
yeah so uh you know I would say I would
say Dave Smith personally but but we
we've always so I don't think he's
announced but we always knew that he was
a contender that he might run so that
one's a little too obvious you know yeah
but like all that power
all that Authority
it goes back to that it goes back to
that Star Wars reference Alex Jones in
the floor going unlimited power
unlimited power
and he's firing you know lasers oh my
God
just imagine them for like he like if if
he ran as a republican made it to the
debates he would pull really high yeah
he absolutely would pull really high
he'd pull enough to get into the
Republican primary debates and he'd be
going off on everybody there it'd be
amazing maybe that's why they had to
cancel maybe the CIA predictive
programming actually foretold foretold a
future where he would have got into
politics ran and then uh who knows what
kind of Calamity would have happened and
they were like we need to stop this at
all costs to ban him now immediately
it's January it's January 20th 2020 uh
2024 oh no I'm 20 25 sorry and uh Alex
Jones was just officially sworn and then
as soon as he is he just turns around
walks inside the Capitol Building walks
out with like a lizard guy and he's like
Arizona I'm done
yeah I just need to get it in the
building
here he is he pulls a mask off of you
know Obama or something no no what he
does yeah Pelosi looks like she has a
master he pardons
um he pardons what's his name Snowden
he pardoned snowed in a song yesange he
he orders the distribution of sunglasses
that allow everyone to see uh Pelosi's
true face
oh I got it I got a mask like that's not
even a joke haven't you seen like the G
Prime 85 art let me see let me pull it
up he pulls out all the supplements and
he says hey everybody everybody I did
not see it everybody gets the
supplements that sounds right
all right here you go I hope you have
stuff to use later for for sure no
worries here you go we got we got a
shout out George alexopoulos it's good
oh yes Nancy Pelosi says it was a setup
I was wearing my mask the same mask I'm
wearing now and she rips her face off
and she's an alien
I reached out to him uh a few months ago
because I want him to do some artwork
for me and he's like yeah sure you know
he gave me a price I have no idea what
like I I want I want him to do something
with my image in like a cool way but I
just don't but I just don't know like
what to ask for like I'm I'm just not
that uh creative I guess he made one of
me getting accused by aliens but he's
super he is super talented he is great
yeah I really like his stuff we're going
to be rotating this my favorite one from
him I think is Joe Biden at a Podium and
he says it is estimated by the time I
finish this this speech 200 million
people will die and that time is now and
then he fires lightning bolts that
vaporizes the crowd that's just one of
the best the crowds like they're like
their heads are being blown back and
they're they're you know their skulls
are showing they're being vaporized by
Biden it's brilliant yeah it's it's
really it's really cool to see these in
the background of this yeah the the I'm
afraid you're not black that's the first
one I ever saw from that one's so great
he's great I mean we should have it back
on yeah I never I never was at the house
when he was on it was uh he seems like
and also Sheamus too yeah Sheamus is
just here yeah so so so we uh in the in
the Vlog the cast Castle Vlog we did
this bit where we say like Sheamus is
the greatest rollerblader but it's very
obviously not Sheamus rollerblading we
just had him like what no way yeah so
but it's funny because like you know we
we had him uh so I had an idea and I was
like uh Sheamus is a freedom tunes for
the Frozen I'm familiar and I was like I
got idea let's have Sheamus rollerblade
around but then we'll put Brett who's
like a legit really good blader in
Sheamus's clothes but he'll wear a
helmet so you can't see and then we'll
claim it's Sheamus and then Sheamus was
like yeah but I need a catchphrase yeah
when I land stuff and I was like no you
got to yell your name that way that way
people know it's you
so what we did is Sheamus was just
yelling things and then Brett is skating
but whenever he lands he goes Sheamus
and then like he jumps like Sheamus and
so now the gag is like whenever you
succeed at something in a sporting event
we yell Sheamus uh you don't you know
yell um let's go Brandon no yeah we do
Yeah we actually so so we were skating
today and you know when someone's trying
a hard trick we go let's go Brandon
oh how about we do this how do we go
super chats yes super chat if you
haven't already smash that like button
do it for Sheamus and uh and Brandon and
Brandon someone there's I gotta read one
super there was one super chat I saw
where they said Robo Biden slash Brandon
2024 yes and I was like yes yeah
[Laughter]
all right all right let's see
doobie McNasty uh smash the like button
become a member at timcast.com you get
the you get it Debbie McNasty says Tim
you gotta watch Alex Jones versus Tim
Poole I've heard good things about it
have you seen it no uh so you know that
people like there's editors that make
these podcasts apparently there's a
really funny one where Alex Jones is I I
don't know what it's about do you know
have you seen it Luke no I don't know
what it's about but apparently really
funny like I've seen The Joe Rogan
versus Joe Rogan there's there's one
earlier where it's like me Michael Mouse
and Alex Jones and we like all love each
other or something it's just they're
really funny but there's like a new one
I guess so
all right I like Michael by the way oh
he's fantastic I I that I'm telling you
the the the time that him and and Alex
run that was just that was just
brilliant and and Michael really can
hold his own with with Alex which is
very hard to do very hard to do
absolutely not even Tim can do it
okay it's hard
all right let's see Group B says Tim I
watched your video about the economy
halt due to the pandemic is this what
was referenced last year when Trump says
this is how economies die it's like
you're stuck between a rock and a hard
place
I will defer to You Luke I'm deferring
back to you
mother
Trump and if if Trump and Alex Jones
have anything in common is it that
they're always right thank you
let's see Darko
vukovic says tell Ian I work for Google
and I heard him we have a group of 324
who have signed an open letter against
the vaccine mandate growing daily Google
HR claims they are working on a
religious exemption TBD loved the show
hey glad to hear it man good
all right let's see
Royal wolf says it's finally happened
Tim has merged with the wall actually
this is a navy blue t-shirt and that is
a black backdrop close we got to show
you the new studio though because you
got here late you didn't see it I heard
I did not get the the new tour yeah so
we were planning on having it done over
the past weekend but they had to do we
were like we gotta clean we had to do
like a steam cleaning because and
polishing the walls and everything we
had to do it which meant we had to delay
product like setting up of the of the
equipment and everything and then I was
like we're not going to be able to do a
good day of testing throughout the week
because we're so busy so it's slowly
getting done and it's amazing the
cameras are all mounted on the walls oh
the table is way bigger there's a booze
section with substantially more booze
we're getting a couch set up we have
more cameras we have a PTZ camera in
there that can move anywhere and point
to anything in the room so you're
basically turning into Crowder's show
we have the couch and stuff yeah well
we're gonna have a couch and it's
because right now we have bean bags and
when people have guests come by they're
just like sitting on the back so we're
gonna have an actual account like like
yesterday with with James O'Keefe uh
what was this friend's name Nick oh he
had a whole crew here whole crew yeah oh
because he kept pointing off camera yeah
right and I and I kept going I kept
thinking it would be great if there were
so we're gonna have mics and stuff for
them right yes so we're gonna have extra
mics we're gonna have a performance area
for music and then a PTZ camera is a pan
tilt zoom and that means we're gonna
have a wide shot we used to have a wide
shot we don't anymore we do the UFO is
back
we have the UFO again we've had I've had
the UFO for a long time it's just been
sitting we don't have anyone to put it
here right and with the wide shot and
the PTZ we can actually have the PTZ
preset to zoom in on the UFO that's
great yeah it'll be fun yeah it's a bit
it's a slightly bigger room and uh it
also has a bathroom in it
which we are sound proofing yes yes oh
but then you're missing out on the whole
married or children thing
that's too bad missed opportunity I'm
sorry
all right let's see Roberto Lara says
twin twin Tim quit lying you have Ian
and bear Patrol alone and naked holding
a shroom voiced by Alex Jones holding a
staff yelling let's End the Fed how did
they know did you see uh the animation
we did about Ian and Alex Jones
possibly one of the funniest things so
uh in the cast Castle Vlog Kent does the
animations and one of the episodes I
can't remember which one it was do you I
don't remember which one it was
um but it's Ian and he like find it's a
cartoon of Ian finding a mushroom and
the mushroom is Alex Jones who's just
screaming and then like saying weird
Alex Jones stuff and then Ian's all
excited it's it's one of the funniest
things I've ever seen it's amazing
yeah all right let's see we got here
one shot Killa says University of
Washington Medical just came out and
said they will not do organ transplants
unless you have the jab even if you if
you have a sincerely held religious
belief yep wow then don't go there yeah
that's it you know there's not a lot of
organs available this is not China
um so this is absolute cruelty and uh
evil in my opinion I mean that that's
that's evil
they're they're making a political yeah
they're
the CDC has even admitted that
that they think that there's over 100
million people that have been infected
with covid so that's a lot of natural
immunity and I'm not saying don't take
the vaccine uh it's your choice you
should if you want to take it
it's it it's going to help you if you're
yeah
that's what they say but you shouldn't
have to take it it's no one's business
but but yours and you said that this
this is the issue I take with like
anybody arguing efficacy and stuff like
this I don't care like I don't want to
hear about someone taking Preparation H
that's your business not mine if you've
got medical conditions going on bro you
don't got to tell me about it unless
like you're sick and I don't want to get
sick you know what I mean
like go to a doctor don't come to me
with that stuff and I'm not gonna tell
you what to do I hate that it's so
political and it shouldn't be political
it should just be and they were they
were talking about oh we need to get to
you know like 70 and went to 75 then it
was 80. now it's like 98 and like no
that's you will never get to zero
covered that's that's the thing that
will never happen because there's more
countries than us and and where we right
you can't con we can't control our
borders clearly I I gotta read this one
this is very important Seth Shoemake
says Tim are you subconsciously
competing with Luke since he's been back
you've estewed the button up and are
showing off the guns and you've got him
lit like Pinhead from Hellraiser tonight
thank you love you both no no no no no
no no
listen to this we have all of these
lights one two three four five six seven
eight that have been set since the
beginning of the show and Luke comes in
and it starts
and makes himself look awful and I keep
telling him I keep saying I'm like Luke
stop your making yourself look worse and
he's like no I want it this way because
I don't want to I gotta look better and
then he zooms the camera out so it makes
his face look really big and his body
looks small and then he turns you're
more zoomed out than I am zoomed out we
have overheared arguments about it right
over here he blasts Ultra at his face no
no that's because that was there with
where Ian was yesterday I didn't even
touch the lights today partly I don't
care but uh uh was the light better yes
was the light better at the beginning of
the broadcast or Midway let me know
right now
where you are yesterday and he looked
fine yeah exactly and now he didn't
change that I had to get up what are you
trying to stay there just now and fix
the light because Luke was fiddling with
everything I fixed it and everyone in
the comment section is saying Luke is
lit okay everyone's saying
[Laughter]
okay all right let's see Sergeant Amos
says Hey folks do you think you could
get a Republican senator on the show and
if so who would you like to have on oh
I'll tell you this right now let me say
something I have reached out to Lauren
bobert who said yes I'd love to come on
the show I was actually I'm sorry I was
actually thinking on the plane when I
was sitting there doing nothing I was
actually thinking that she would be
amazing on this true Dan Crenshaw also
now the problem is
Dan said he was unable to
um just because it's like really
difficult in his schedule everyone to
like come out for an hour and he's like
but we'll maybe figure something out and
I'm like yeah whatever no pressure I get
it Lauren just said contact my you know
this person and we'll take care of it
and then they just ignore me and then
this has been it's been this way for I
can't list off every single politician
we've asked but we've asked a handful of
Republicans who all say the same thing
yes absolutely would love to do it reach
out to this person I think Matt Gates
too yeah yeah they were like yes contact
my my person who will take care of it
all and then they should ignore you yep
so it's like basically they say yes but
they really mean no so I'll tell you the
other thing 99 of the politicians we've
had which hasn't been that many it's
just like politicians don't talk
politicians are very careful they're
very very careful it's not as fun it's
not as funny they don't want to they
want they don't want they don't want to
lose any potential vote so it's just but
I think that there's definitely some
people out there where you wouldn't
necessarily have to talk about current
events you wouldn't have to like say hey
what's in the news today what do you
think sir you know
I think that there are some really
interesting people that you could have
on on but I just don't feel it uh but
Sean Parnell has been the best because
he's an outlier he's like he's a regular
dude he was when he's on the show he's a
congress person oh he's running for
Senate but yeah but he wait isn't he
he's running for oh no I'm thinking I'm
sorry I'm thinking of somebody else no
yeah like I I think that you could have
somebody on here like I I would love
hold on Dave Smith and the libertarian
guys are like legit the music guys are
like I'll say exactly like I'm sure like
Massey would come and talk to you the
problem is we it's like almost a waste
of energy to try and even talk to them
in the first place because I tell you
this it is when we when we reach out to
anybody else they're usually like hey
sorry I can't do it um but I'll let you
know if my if the dates open up we're
talking a handful of people some high
profile people and they're like looking
really busy but let's let's try and
figure this out politicians are always
absolutely here's the email from my
assistant email them and we'll get it
done and then they just don't respond or
they respond and say how are these dates
and they they they bounce you around and
then eventually just disappear
just like I'm like dude not only that
it is there there you got to be I don't
know man uh I'm I'm wary about any of
these politicians I don't care if
they're a Republican or otherwise
because you know that you've gotta you
may end up getting canned opinions oh
yeah they're gonna be they're gonna
protect their reputation and they don't
want to and probably the reason they
don't want to come on the show is they
know that I'm that I might say something
like hey X just happened in the news
what do you think and they go uh oh like
can they handle a two-hour conversation
where they have to be like open and
honest with like this is not this is not
a one sentence question and you leave
yeah this is two hours and that means
you're either gonna say nothing or
you're going to answer questions and
talk about how you feel about it and
that's why I think somebody like Lauren
bobert would just be perfect because
she's outspoken she's smart too she's
she's not
and and uh actually you know you know
who I'll say saw uh I watched the Tucker
Carlson uh Marjory Taylor Green
interview
uh when on Fox Nation nice she's
she's not a lunatic she's a very smart
woman and she came across as as very
reasonable and not a lunatic and I was
just like why can't we see this you know
like you have to be you have to be uh
subscribed to Fox Nation I guess uh but
she's she's smart she but then she says
something crazy anyway and you're just
like oh what are you doing like like
don't go there like you need you need to
kind of dial it back a little bit but
um I would love to see I would love to
interview Chuck Grassley by the way I
think he'd have oh yeah a bajillion
great stories especially like the stuff
during uh you know the uh the Kavanaugh
hearings and uh and uh Justice Clarence
Thomas because he's featured in that
that documentary I think just talking
about stuff like Chuck grassy he's
smarter like he's old he's going to run
for Senate again like yeah he runs he
runs like three miles a day yeah but we
just need to get rid of incumbents man
uh but he's not Dianne Feinstein you
know what I mean like he's actually
still you know he's he has more brain
cells left young energy you know but I I
don't care about the Republicans to be
honest because
what have they ever done you know rubs
Luke's uh rubbing off in you let's let's
read some more we got pims pims says
Newport News shipbuilding is about to
lose 50 percent of its workers over the
Mandate you all need a shipbuilder wow
that's crazy but I I briefly lived in
Newport News like only a couple months
yeah there's a military base there oh I
remember that yeah yeah yeah yeah
Newport News
uh good fun that was a long time ago is
there an Andrew Centric Super Chat on
there somebody quick Andrew well we got
we got a member Dilly Dilly says if only
Candace Owens would banish bite into
California like Lady Galadriel in The
Hobbit
yes excellent but we're not doing
fantasy references we've been doing uh
sci-fi the whole time yeah yeah wrong
show Jerk come on he's so dumb I mean
right it's like Stargate come on Lord
yeah now our big Lord of the Rings nerd
big big Lord of the Rings fans
all right let's see
let's see uh Thomas stankovic says you
said wouldn't it be awesome to see a
press secretary Mike malis as if y'all
ain't gonna be co-workers can't fight
Destiny forever baby oh yeah yeah yeah I
think we would help I think we would oh
definitely definitely like to the extent
that we could I definitely love to uh
you know but um Michael malice as the
press secretary would be like taking a
gigantic bucket of ice water and
splashing people in the face with it who
are all not paying attention I think
it'd be fantastic hey speaking of
co-workers uh just want to say hi to
Cassandra Fairbanks oh she's fantastic
she's awesome with her with her new
monkey she's had her for yes like six
weeks now and speaking of monkeys Lauren
Chen's gonna have a little a little baby
monkey to play with you're like a monkey
too not not a real monkey no
congratulations to Lauren Michael
Michael malice will be able to craft
responses in such a way that it makes it
very difficult for the media to try and
stop reporting on something you know
unless they just literally don't report
what he's saying but like I I think his
ability his understanding of like
Linguistics and manipulation is making
he'd make it very very difficult for
them to pull things out of context and
then you'd get weird stories where the
regular you know public might be like
what
I think it'll be fantastic plus he'd
been insulting them into varying degrees
so that's good
all right let's see what we got let's
read some more
just Jenny says I love Andrew I'm so
glad he's back on the show no finally no
Andrew we poo poo I don't know man I try
I should try it uh to be fair Lydia's
been asking me uh you know if I could
come to the show I've been pestering you
right and uh she's she has been
pestering me and of course I come the
day where my flight's totally screwed
over but uh I to be fair I was I was I
have been busy and I was I've been
slowly building my presence in Florida
so uh lots of furniture to build stuff
like that so I've been you know just now
that I'm now that I only have like one
or two more things to do we got a
question from here come up here storm
Viking says hello don't walk run hello I
was wondering what part of Florida you
moved to also are you hiring for your
show or in need of a Florida guide thank
you I am not hiring uh I am a one-man
band because I don't
come on I'm a conservative well not I'm
not really conservative but I'm a
conservative YouTuber so uh
good luck I don't make a lot of money uh
so but definitely not enough to hire
people and I'm probably just gonna keep
my area
you know Florida how's that
um but I will say that uh I I passed the
background check and I'm really excited
oh wonderful really excited very good
yeah all right I just I just got a 2A
people 2A yes well I can do it I bought
this Calico m100s
which is a 100 round
was it what what is it called it's um
Helix yeah Helix it's not a drum mag
yeah something else really holds 122 uh
rounds probably gonna Jam a lot I'd
imagine and it's like it's like a weird
looking sci-fi gun you know but it's
like sure looks I can't wait to get to
the right you gotta find the right 22s
to make sure that that shoots well do
you have a first one or do you have one
that you're looking for uh no I have I I
have two Firearms very cool do you care
too
I said I I want all the guns okay
uh I I bought an HK P30
okay very cool gun it's like it's not
even I didn't I I had no idea what I
wanted honestly uh and I just said I'm
you know just show me some guns you know
and uh and then of course I I look at
the HK and it's it's such a cool gun and
they're like oh well that's the I said I
think I'll I'll buy it Sterling what do
you like about it I'm like well it's
light and you know and they're like
that's the John Wick gun I'm like it's
not you know why I'm buying it but you
know it's cool good one of my favorites
is one the first kind of bought was the
is the uh the governor can fire 410 or
45 and firing 410 out of that thing is
just hilarious Luke was at the range
with us and he just loaded up he's like
boom boom boom boom and it's just like
everyone's like you're shooting shotgun
shells out of a revolver you know well I
brought my guns in the plane you want to
take a look no no I'm kidding that's why
the plane was delayed wow
don't even joke about this good work
Andrew all right f-man Angry American
says Tim quarterback Drew Bress number
nine for the Saints was forced to
support the rapist he came out against
him at first but peer pressure made him
change his mind imagine being able to be
peer pressured into supporting a rapist
can you believe that wow that guy's got
no smile at least the people who support
it have the spine enough to say they do
this guy was like oh geez I guess I
should wow
some people man sad
Doobie mcnastics has timed that
description of the writtenhouse case was
phenomenal he didn't hold anything back
it was like we uh we were in the members
only video I love all of it well yeah
but you know that's it's just the truth
and if the truth is the truth it's the
truth we say it
yup uh I saw writtenhouse was trending
and everyone's like he's a terrorist and
they and they all just lie about what
happened please everybody lies they lie
about everything I know it's just they
live in in in a swamp that's what it is
they're just mucking around in human
feces it's the same people that are like
Trump's going to jail like yeah right
Trump hasn't even Trump hasn't been
president and
right it seems like four years yeah all
right Dragon Lady says read your segment
earlier Tim I work in a grocery store
folks Tim is Right stock up on
non-perishables it's crazy how much
stuff we can't get in on a side note
love your stuff Andrew oh thank you
that's very kind of you there's a rice
shortage well did you know that you know
first of all I was really excited
earlier this year because you know for
over the Fourth of July we saved 16
cents oh yeah on our barbecues and that
was a big deal and I'm like you know
what it's beef prices are dollar you
know
but 16 cents come on the the local
barbecue the local barbecue stop uh over
here in Virginia doesn't sell brisket
anymore they said it's too expensive
nobody will know they can't sell it well
it's too expensive to get that's that's
crazy so it's like a barbecue place with
no brisket
what am I supposed to do I do a brisket
there is a place off the side of the
road down in Virginia that has the best
brisket I've ever had
it is a huge thick cut cooked overnight
man it's insanely delicious and it only
cost five thousand dollars 20 bucks
20 bucks for a you know big cut but
everything everything is expensive yeah
and and just traveling around Florida by
the way uh you can see why because
everybody's hiring every single place is
hiring and when they're hiring and they
they they're trying to get people they
gotta pay them higher wages whether or
not that job is worth that much money
let's let's be real you know most of
these restaurant jobs not not to say
that working in a restaurant is bad it's
it some of my favorite jobs have been
working in restaurants but they they're
not worth thirty dollars an hour you
know you can any job where you can
completely train on your own
at the restaurant or wherever
is not worth that much
we got we got to switch out here from
poofy poofy what's up yes she says Robo
Biden would just be a Roomba that yells
incoherently
it bounces around randomly and then gets
stuck in the corner when it falls off
the carpet gotta yell it a lot I uh I
bought a Roomba by the way how'd that go
I bought the Roomba and it was over
um
some some Black Friday thing maybe or no
no the Amazon Prime thing I bought I
bought the the vacuum and I bought the
mop
because I'm a lazy wow yeah
who doesn't want to I love it and and I
called and I called it Robo Biden yeah
leg uh so so I I just don't know how to
pronounce your name but I'm gonna
pronounce it however I can leguma figion
there's probably it's probably it's
probably a word I don't know be careful
who you mock Biden is definitely a Goa
old picture his eyes flashing yellow his
voice gets all demonic he cries out
don't knock Java Cree instantly the
death gliders descend from his pyramid
ship and wipe out the cast Castle or
he'll give you a symbiote oh snap yeah
he's right well he's well Biden's
dangerous already I mean he what you
know he killed like seven children the
other day it was pretty cool oh yeah he
blew him up he's
hold on if if he's not blowing up kids
who's gonna do it you know yeah what
what you think Donald Trump's gonna do
it come on yeah we we've got we've got
we've got a Child Problem on this planet
you know and and good Heroes like Obama
over popular Biden jeez you know Trump
did drone strikes as well and Trump did
order Commando raids now here's a here's
the thing I want to clarify did he kill
Aid workers well there was reporting
that Donald Trump uh ordered a Commando
raid that killed an eight-year-old
American Girl the sister of Abdullahi
however
they say may have and suspected to it's
very different from Barack Obama's oops
we killed an American citizen so I'm
wondering if Trump if the commander raid
actually was the res the cause either
way I'm not a fan of that foreign policy
agreed
all right let's see what we got here
gavon uh Gavin deth death says Jones
malice 2024.
[Music]
Brian I like it if not president can
Alex Jones moderate the debates
no one would speak Hansen says Tim Alex
Jones impression on point also when are
you coming to the great state of Iowa
no idea we're we're building up the new
studio that's Chuck Grassley State
that's right then we're gonna be
building out the mobile Studio
because we want to go to Nashville and
Austin and we all want to go to Florida
so we have this mobile women RV it's a
it's a fifth wheel trailer it's got a
kitchen it's got a bathroom it's got
seats and everything and we're actually
putting cameras and setting it up so
we'll be able to do the show on the road
and the idea would be that we go to
Nashville but we pre-line up guests all
basically which is likely going to be
like daily wire crew people hopefully
then we go to Austin and we basically
got everybody you got you know you know
Sydney and Elijah you've got Alex in his
crew you've got Crowder and everybody
there's a lot and then you go to Florida
where you got did Dave Rubin move there
yet is he moving to Florida yeah not yet
I there's a lot of people in Florida but
you're you're a guest earlier this week
I mean I do my videos in my RV and
having those fifth wheels is very
convenient there's a lot of room in
there and I've been living in one for
over a year yeah yours is very spacious
yeah I love it yeah and it's not even
that like brand new it's it's you know
it's like it's very affordable it's
bigger than my apartment in New York
City and I love it yeah I feel like the
one we got is a long one but Luke's has
more interior space for some reason well
it has a lot of slide outs yeah so mine
has like three major slide outs that
totally transition everything I know a
lot of people want to do the van life
stuff but they don't understand the
larger implications I know uh YouTube is
trying to find Landry didn't understand
the applications yeah and I mean just
being on the road alone and traveling
with people in small spaces is is
difficult it definitely tests any kind
of relationships you have but
um you know people don't understand van
life that's promoted that that life is
is pretty hard RV life is not that easy
as well but a lot easier when you have a
big fifth wheel well I also think it has
it's easier when you have a purpose
you're not just like an influenster you
know walking around going hey we need to
take pictures about a Grand Canyon man
you know like when you're actually like
say we're going to this town to
interview people so you you better be
going to Florida with your uh that's
what I've been super van that's what
I've been trying all right say hello I
got I gotta address this York says Tim
if you are truly starting a
fact-checking website will you keep a
running tally of Alex Jones versus all
mainstream media sources on percentage
correct versus retracted yes what I
wanted to do is are you doing a fact
checking site yeah we have two
non-profits we filed and the filings are
in we're just waiting for tax exempt
status but the entities exist uh it's
called this I didn't come up with
politics truth and media Foundation
someone
who was here I guess and we thought it
was funny but the idea is to do fact
checking and what we want to do is it's
not so much as fact check like like did
Alex Jones get it right it's here's what
Alex Jones was talking about and then if
Alex Jones has something like that
turning the freaking frogs gay we'll be
like the you know what we'll do is we'll
say
the article in reference that Alex Jones
was referring to was about an atrazine
pesticide here's the article and then
what whatever is hyperbole or
exaggeration or otherwise you can just
read the articles so instead of us being
saying like he's clearly lying we'll be
like here's the article he referenced
read it and draw a conclusion and then
Alex Jones gets three beanies three
beanies now what we're gonna do is and
we'll do this for Infowars in any other
site we're gonna go through their
articles looking for violations of
journalistic ethics and then we're going
to randomly sample 100 recent articles
then we're going to give them a score
say you know this website has 65 out of
100 articles deemed ethical here's the
spreadsheet showing all the Articles we
reviewed the ones we rated as unethical
and the ones rated as ethical so uh
false information is unethical and like
failure to correct or opinion pieces or
maximizing harm so if not like CNN when
they published that factory worker's
name saying here's the guy who posted in
the meme of Pelosi we would give that an
X and say maximization of harm see and
then we would write CNN had no reason to
publish the name and job of an
individual who posted a video online to
tell the story they needed to tell
journalistic ethics standards from spj
says minimize harm meaning if you don't
have to cause damage to someone's life
don't do it then there's also opinions
most of these articles are opinions
they'll put adjectives in places and I
guarantee you man you'll be surprised
CNN will probably get a 10 out of 100
because so many of their articles are
going to turn out to be opinion like
when they when they frame something in a
certain way that is not factual when
they say experts agree on this we
interviewed so-and-so X will be like
citing an opinion from a single expert
does not guarantee a fact we cannot
State this is a true this is an opinion
piece based on the opinion so when you
look at a lot of these stories they'll
say we'll talk to an opinion who said it
can't possibly be that it rained today
because the expert at Stanford believes
that rain actually one expert's opinion
is an opinion piece right not a fact
piece so we would put X opinion
unlabeled and then you'll see a lot of
these news outlets will be like getting
very seriously bad scores that being
said I don't think Infowars would do
well I don't think a lot of conservative
sites would do well either now what
we're focusing on is the daily wire for
instance is overtly conservative opinion
and perspective we will not give a
strike to someone who's overtly a
conservative or liberal like like uh
alternate for instance we know they're
Progressive activists so we're not going
to say we're not going to come to a
place where it's like you're literally
getting Progressive or conservative
activism or commentary and then get mad
that they're doing it we'll just put a
label saying this isn't you know a site
that it that focuses on an ideology
pretending to the left in their
perspective
but then we'll go in and say that's
factually incorrect that maximizes harm
so uh opinion websites and commentary uh
and and things like that we're not going
to strike for being opinion or
commentary unless they're not labeled as
such and when do you think truth in
media it's already so here's the issue
it's already done but it could take a
few months for tax exam status to go
through I see which means we can't put
money into it until we have the official
you know confirmation of tax exempt
status okay uh it's not gonna do
anything political so it's it's probably
not going to go anywhere near fact
checking politicians just media
organizations and uh maybe like
University content where they do
articles and studies and then we have
another one which is the the Open Open
Network Foundation which is we're
building social media technology to
prevent to make it so people can't be
banned anymore so specifically we're
making an open source free version of a
subscription pay service
so that anyone can easily just go to the
website click download drop the the file
onto their server for their website and
then all of a sudden they have their own
version of patreon no one can ever ban
it they're certain their hosting server
can kick them off they can find a new
server their DNS can go after them
whatever but there's not going to be a
centralized Twitter or patreon to ban
them and then this technology connects
with something called the fetaverse
which is a decentralized open source
um like social network system so then
what I'll do is I'll go to a website
like Gaba for instance gab is on the
fediverse and then I'll put you know
follow you know Bob bob.com which will
link to his server so gab Can't Ban him
they can just block access to their
servers from his and anyway the idea is
if I have my own website which functions
as my own private patreon
patreon Can't Ban me I could only ban
myself
then if people want to you know give
money you don't got to worry about
giving a fraction a portion of your
money to someone else we're going to be
using open source uh a decentralized
video hosting so it'll be free for the
most part which will be one of the
cheapest options available so we I think
we're looking at Odyssey because Odyssey
is like you know free to upload okay and
so people then can then post videos to
their own site post articles to their
own site have a subscriber only option
people can then you know I'm gonna hit
10 bucks a month to this website to be a
member and then you have people having
without like if you sign up for patreon
or subscribe star or locals or whatever
you've got to give a percentage of your
income with this open source free
software building which will make no
money on
you don't got to do that stay tuned
ladies and gentlemen it's it's it's
happening I think they actually launched
like a their like the the crew's been
building it they're in Alpha and they've
just been building it regardless of the
story so now we want to hire people
officially to do this stuff and we've
got some people who are interested in
making donations but we have to wait
until the new year probably so that we
we can get our IRS filing for 51c3
status it is going the goal is to Des to
to strengthen the decentralized networks
of communication to prevent nefarious
political actors from you know it's it's
you know we'll we'll see how it plays
out there's always decentralized social
media Network attempts and they never
get too big but the goal is so that
people can make a living so that instead
of having to go so so right now people
tell me like why use patreon well
because patreon is a network and someone
can go into patreon and give 10 bucks to
all their favorite creators in one place
with what we're building you'll be able
to do that you'll be able to sign up in
in in all these different websites will
be networked through this so there will
actually be like a like a recommended a
top trending section and all that stuff
that people will be able to go to to see
this network of of crater accounts and
no one can ban it that's the best part
that also means there'll be a lot of bad
people but that's the internet and
that's anything that goes over the line
is going to be responsible for law
enforcement not for some you know despot
at Twitter or whatever so we're hoping
that decentralized technology will help
people have careers prevent them from
having their lives destroyed by
Psychopaths like you know Zuckerberg and
then just generally create a more robust
and balanced uh political environment
it's gonna be fun anyway my friends
smash the like button if you haven't
done it already all those great projects
are only possible because you guys are
members at timcast.com so like I said
when you become a member
money comes in we are we are now using
that we did legal filings for these
networks we are not going to make money
off the open source open source project
or the fact checking we are literally
saying you as members are funding the
building of important work to try and
solve these problems the other thing
we're doing is we're building culture we
have details from the inverted world we
have the cast Castle Vlog we now have a
new show in the works talking about pop
culture Comics movies and that's what
you are basically helping create as
members not to mention we're getting you
all the stuff so thanks for being
members you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast and uh Andrew do you want to
show anything up yeah follow me uh
follow me at don't walk run all one word
don't walk run on Twitter and you can
look up Don't Walk Run Productions on
YouTube uh but definitely follow me on
Twitter because uh that's where all the
spicy stuff is that's right that's where
I uh you know curse and get all nasty to
people including uh John Fogle saying
yeah that's cool I want to say one thing
I I gotta I gotta say one thing Luke
truly does have the best
politicalshirts.com yes
he has a website now the shirts are no
no uh legit like I was looking at how
you sketched the two plus two equals
five and I was like those are good
shirts man I have a great team I I can't
thank them enough they're really awesome
they're incredible so yeah the shirt I
have on says two plus two equals five
you bigot and it gets a lot of attention
a lot of thumbs up but I'm also doing a
collective art piece with the house with
the Vlog so uh I just got a room
officially inside of the house and
there's the the room's bare I have one
wall I'm dead I'm dedicating it to the
audience whatever you send to the Tim
cast uh mailing PO box that I could put
on the wall whether it's a sign whether
it's a poster whether it's a picture I
will have to put it up on this one wall
we will truly see what your fans are
like and they can mail stuff to
you can mail me your housewarming gifts
or your posters to P.O box 1229
Frederick Maryland
21702 and of course I'm going to be
documenting it on my social media but of
course it's going to be on the Vlog and
I think it'll be interesting to see
everyone kind of pitch in into this uh
art piece which I think is going to be
interesting to say it's going to be 50
Gadsden Flags in a week or it could be
other things we can't even say on the
show which I don't know uh it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting so I I I think
it's a good way to spark the
conversation but also have this kind of
uh like like this this everything just
regurgitated on that wall that
represents this show so whatever you
want the show to represent or whatever
you want to to represent the larger
ideas expressed here uh mail it like
like please yeah but bunch of dollar
bills like that'd be so interesting I
would have to put I wouldn't be able to
use it but I would have to put it on the
wall but if you can just try to avoid
using Amazon try to use something that
helps people like Etsy and eBay that
people directly could use and and try to
use as much Independent Business as you
can if you're going to be mailing
anything that's my only request so I
keep looking I've I've across from Luke
and I keep seeing the shirt and I and I
keep reading it in Carl Benjamin's voice
you know because he it he would that's
exactly you would say you pick it
up
I'm not gonna say it but I I love the
little Cedars I love Carl and Callum
they're awesome yeah shut up um and uh
we we need to say goodbye to Lydia
that's right I was gonna say okay I am
really curious to see what all our
audience sends to Luke to hang on the
wall I'm a little bit anxious about
whatever people said and I have to put
it up that's the rules I have to put it
up on the wall said I would open a box
of bees yeah
I'm scared you guys please send Luke
good things to hang on his wall you guys
may follow me on Twitter at Sour Patch
let's worth the follow that's true make
sure you check out youtube.com cast
castle for all of our fun Vlog
Shenanigans and uh it's Friday night
baby we're gonna go hit the casino we'll
see y'all next time